[Music]
did I ask you to please take your seats
for this Saturday morning class
now to those of you who are young men
and young women that's defined by the
way by my standard which is you're
younger than I am many of you don't
remember the great pleasure that MIT
invested on all of us who are my age and
older which was Saturday morning class
typically these were laboratory classes
they were hard to get to
they were harder to be in and they were
usually impossible to perform in fact
frequently one got a whole new sense of
appreciation for men like Michelson and
Morley who produced experiments which
are totally reproducible I'm convinced
they threw out all the data except the
one that fit their theory but of course
their theory was correct so it doesn't
make any difference as they say my name
for those of you who don't know me is
Bill Hecht I'm a member of the class of
1961 I was a Sloan fellow in 1976 and 18
years ago I took this job for five years
and somehow or other have lost the
capacity to count or enjoy myself a
great deal I'm executive vice president
Association and your senior employee
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
all back to technology day this year I
usually don't start with a an apology
but as many of you know who were here
yesterday we had this visitor who seemed
to cause untoward an unconscionable
distress among many people largely by
causing traffic jams on every major and
minor artery in Cambridge closing an
airport here or there having helicopters
land on brick field and giving a major
address at commencement the most
distressing thing to me at least and as
you all know I am an MIT loyalist was
looking at the evening news while I was
shaving to go to dinner with a class
last night in recognizing that
some rock promoter named Don Henley got
more press coverage than his MIT
commencement speech but oh well I guess
that's a that's more a comment on the
media than it is on substance it's my
great pleasure this morning to kick off
this program I think we have a great one
as we always do and it's always a
special treat to introduce my good
friend Chuck vest Chuck came to us from
the University of Michigan following by
the way in the tradition of another MIT
President Jerry Wiesner who came from
the University of Michigan and Chuck has
become very much a part of MIT and those
of you were at pops on Thursday night
know that we made his wife an honorary
alumna following Chuck so we now have a
first family both of whom are honorary
alumni and alumnae Chuck vest
Thank You bill and good morning everyone
on behalf of the students faculty and
staff of the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology I'm absolutely delighted to
welcome you back to Cambridge and to
welcome MIT back to some semblance of
reasonable common normalcy after
yesterday's commencement exercises I
know that many of you were not able to
be in Killian Court but I opened my part
of the program by telling the assembled
graduates and families that last week a
faculty member had said to me that she
really thought I was a model president
and I was very proud and pleased and
sort of floating on top of the ground
until I went home and looked in the
dictionary and discovered that a model
is a small replica of the real thing and
we had the real thing with us yesterday
together with a very distinguished
scientist and graduate of our joint
health science and technology program
with Harvard dr. David Howe I'm told
that it's good to tell inside stories
about the President of the United States
while I have my chance so I'll tell you
what he wanted to share with their
students yesterday we had an opportunity
for mr. Clinton to spend about 20 or 25
minutes together with Paul and Priscilla
gray Alex and Brett d'arbeloff Becky and
myself and about 14 of our undergraduate
student leaders all of whom admitted to
me later that they were so awed by the
presence of the President of the United
States they forgot most of the questions
they had planned to ask but he opened by
telling us that he had recently visited
the grade school and that a very very
young person their first grader or so
after everybody to ask lots of things
looked at him very seriously and said
are you the real President of the United
States and he said yes I am and the
toddler looked at him and said then why
aren't you dead
[Laughter]
well as many of you know this was the
first time that we've had a sitting US
president address an MIT graduating
class and although our staff carried off
the entire event with their usual great
skill and aplomb I must tell you we were
absolutely astonished by the logistical
complexity of this undertaking as they
sometimes say on television ads do not
try this at home
in fact I'd recommend that we not try it
again for another 10 years or so as I
told the class of 58 last night the
statistics of this undertaking were
astounding we had 300 police officers on
campus yesterday we had the commencement
speaker arrived with motorcade
consisting of 44 zero vehicles and we
had snipers on the roof building shut
down and unfortunately as you know a lot
of traffic congestion but one of the
things I was really proud of and also
pleased to note that a lot of the TV
channels picked up at least yesterday
morning was this typical MIT approach of
creating a big group of MIT ambassadors
which were literally a hundred or so of
our very dedicated and devoted staff
some of whom are from the association of
alumni and alumni who just simply
wandered the crowds keeping everybody
happy answering questions solving
problems as they arose and it's those
touches that I think make this such a
magnificent institution to be a part of
so therefore I want to take this
opportunity to thank the entire
community and as I said including many
in this room for helping us really put
our best foot forward on a day when the
whole world was watching as indeed it
was the address was rung at least once
last night on c-span and as well as
being broadcast live on the Internet in
one sense however I would suppose you
could argue that the entire world is
always keeping an eye on MIT our
institutions reputation for
excellence in academics and research is
exceeded only by our graduates
reputation for innovative
entrepreneurship the world looks to MIT
and its graduates for the ideas and the
technologies that enrich our lives and
drive our global economy whether the
topic is the digital transformation of
society or the complex interplay of
human activity with the global climate
ocean and other natural systems with
amazing growth of biomedical knowledge
or the breakthrough developments and
chemistry's and material science or the
latest discoveries on the frontiers of
physics and astronomy you will never
find MIT very far from the absolute
center of the action the world looks to
us and to our graduates for innovative
leadership in many dimensions and for
nearly half of one and a half centuries
we have done our best to provide just
that the topic for today's discussion is
a natural extension of the way the world
looks at MIT the Institute is seen and
rightfully so as pragmatic productive
productive and energetic as a university
a university that engages directly in
the world of commerce industry and
public policy the MIT ethos recognizes
and indeed celebrates the value of
entrepreneurism nothing could be more
fitting than that we invite our alumni
and alumnae to join us today in a
discussion entitled creating wealth
knowledge skills capital resources
you're going to spend the day talking
about just how value and wealth are
created through the development of new
knowledge through prudent investment in
education and training through the
development of skills and expertise
needed to bring new products services
and technologies into the marketplace
and into society before we go too far
down that road of entrepreneur ISM
however we should take a moment to
reflect on the fact that the value of an
institution like MIT certainly cannot be
measured
and definitely not primarily in terms of
its impact on society's financial bottom
line our impact on the economy is one of
the qualities that distinguishes us
among our peers but we should be very
clear to ourselves and to the
communities we serve but this is only
one of the roles which shape our
activities and define our reputation in
recent years technology days explored
the role of MIT in world war two the
Arts at MIT the oceans is a new frontier
and even the role of Technology and
athletics and entertainment mit is proud
of the impact of its graduates and of
our faculty on the world in many
dimensions what we do to fuel a vigorous
economy is the means to the end of
higher quality of life and health
throughout the world as we begin our
discussions then let us recall that the
best way to celebrate entrepreneurism at
MIT is to see it in the larger context
the Institute's deep and abiding
commitment to fundamental inquiry and
scholarly discourse to the creation and
to the sharing of knowledge that is the
real secret that underlies our
entrepreneurial success when we talk
about wealth and MIT we are talking not
simply about economic or monetary
abundance you're also talking about the
beauty and inherent worth of the quest
for knowledge we're talking about the
transforming power of ideas and insights
which enrich our intellectual lives
expand our lifespans preserve the
goodness of our natural environment help
us to understand the mysteries of our
own behavioral and social problems and
light our path forward in the great
adventure of human existence this is at
the core of what we do and why we do it
some of life's greatest rewards come not
when we seek profit but when we seek
understanding knowledge and wisdom along
the way however we often find that these
discoveries have the power
to transform our economy their fortunes
as well all this was in fact forecast by
William Barton Rogers our founder when
he conceived of his original plan for
MIT a kind of educational institution
that emphasized and I'm quoting Rogers
the value of science and it's great
modern applications to the practical
arts of life to human comfort and health
and to social wealth and power that is
what we are here to discuss this morning
so let's get on with it
to address this broader contact of
wealth and value we've assembled an
exceptionally engaging group of speakers
to lead off this morning's panel I'm
going to introduce all of them now and
then ask each to simply come up and
speak in turn and then as I will
indicate in a moment we will open up for
questions and answers our first
distinguished speaker will be dr. Toni
Kate Ann the Deputy Prime Minister and
Minister of Defence of Singapore dr.
thanh holds honor
excuse-me holds an honours degree in
physics from the University of Singapore
a 1964 SM degree from MIT and a PhD in
applied mathematics from the University
of Adelaide he first won election to
Singham or a Singapore's Parliament in
1979 and was appointed as Minister of
Education in 1980 after serving in
several ministerial posts throughout the
1980s he moved back to the private
sector where he served as chairman and
CEO of the oversea Chinese Banking
Corporation dr. thanh returned to
government service in 1995 dr. thanh
will be followed by Judith Sela went
senior vice president and chief
financial officer of Merkin company Judy
Lu aunt came to MIT as a graduate
student the Sloan School following her
graduation from Goucher College with the
BS and economics equipped with an SM
degree in management in 1970
- she went forth to conquer the business
world where her financial and managerial
skills led her into a series of senior
positions in the International
pharmaceuticals industry she's held her
current position at Merck since 1992
Judy is also a member of the board of
directors of Motorola and Quaker Oats in
addition she serves as a trustee of the
Rockefeller family trust and to our good
fortune was member of the MIT
corporation and its executive committee
and she also chairs the corporation's
visiting Committee for the MIT Sloan
School of Management now Judy is a tough
act to follow
but Professor David H marks will try in
fact like myself Dave will try anything
if it's for the betterment of MIT dave
is the crafts professor of civil and
environmental engineering here at the
Institute and I suspect has more than a
few students in the gay in today's
audience a member of the MIT faculty
since 1969 professor marks founded the
Institute's program for environmental
education and research in 1992 his
pioneering initiative has since evolved
into the internationally renowned center
for environmental initiatives as that
center's director professor marks plays
a leading role in the continuing
worldwide effort to bring
interdisciplinary cooperation education
and research to the challenge of
environmental analysis planning and
policy making few modern scientific
missions are more important than that
finally we will round out the opening
remarks with comments from Lester C
Thoreau who currently holds the Jerome
and Dorothy Lemelson professorship of
management and economics and of course
as the former Dean of the Sloan School
Lester Thurow graduated from Williams
College in 1960 took his MA degree at
Oxford Balliol College as a Rhodes
Scholar and earned a PhD in economics at
Harvard in 1964 he has been an honorary
alumnus of MIT since 1991
Lester served on the President's Council
of Economic Advisors during the
administration of Lyndon Johnson he came
to MIT in 1968 and is going on to
achieve a global reputation as a
prolific and respected scholar
commentator author and teacher professor
Thoreau is an expert in entrepreneurism
and believe me he practices what he
preaches taken together these four
speakers embody the strength and
diversity of the richness of the MIT
experience and I therefore should not
keep them from you any longer dr. tan
[Applause]
president vests ladies and gentlemen our
first like to thank president vests and
the technology day committee for
inviting me to speak to you it is
beautiful morning indeed since living
MIT some 34 years ago in 1964 I have not
known the weather in Cambridge to be so
beautiful yesterday the topic of my
speech this morning is creating national
wealth from the perspective of my
country Singapore my speech will be in
three parts
I will first describe briefly how
Singapore developed from a small fishing
village to the modern metropolis that it
is today I will then speak on the
current situation in the Southeast Asian
region and then I'll conclude with some
remarks on how Singapore sees the way
ahead but let me begin with a year 1865
when MIT open classes in Boston with an
enrollment of 15 students bringing to
realization William Barton Rogers years
of work to organize an institution of
higher learning which would be devoted
to scientific and technical training in
that same year 1865 the island of
Singapore which is roughly the size of
the city of Chicago was already in its
46th year as a British trading
settlement at the southern tip of the
Straits of Malacca
could I have slight one please and this
is what Singapore look like at a time by
some accounts when Sir Stamford Raffles
first landed in Singapore in a year 1819
and acquired the tiny island for the
British East India Company the
population of the island numbered about
150 living in a few shabby
and dependent on fishing for their
livelihood but in a months and years to
come the news about the establishment of
the free port of Singapore would attract
many traders and adventurers to a shows
in search of profit and a new life slide
2 when the news of Singapore reached the
southern parts of China Chinese traders
who have previously traveled to places
such as Malaysia Brunei and Manila found
it safer and more profitable to wait to
visit Singapore instead Chinese Chung's
brought with them goats and large
numbers of immigrants the news of a
trading centre in Singapore also reached
the Indian subcontinent and Indian
traders and immigrants soon came to the
island in large numbers slightly so at a
time when MIT first started holding
classes across the Charles River in
Boston on the other side of the world
Singapore was starting to flourish as an
important trading post in the east for
the British Empire in 1916 mit moved to
his present campus here in Cambridge and
about the same time Singapore which are
still a British colony continued to grow
as a enter pole trading port but
Singapore success was not without
problems
the British had encouraged immigration
but did not pay enough attention to the
basic welfare needs of a rapidly growing
population
as you can see immigrants face poverty
and bad living conditions then came war
in 1942 235 and Japanese occupation of
Singapore during World War two
demonstrated the inability of the
British forces to protect the people of
colonies and understandably the return
of British rule after war met with
demands for independence and in time
these demands became too strong for the
British to resist
that's the proclamation of independence
in Singapore in 1965 a union of
Singapore with independent Malaya in the
early 1960s from 63 to 65 proved to be
brief and unhappy and after a few years
as part of Malaysia Singapore left the
Federation and became an independent
sovereign state in 1965 under the shadow
of racial riots unemployment poverty and
ethnic strife it is not surprising that
many commentators confidently predicted
at a time of separation in 1965 that
Singapore in view of his lack of natural
resources could not survive as an
independent state but the island whether
the difficult years of the separation
establish his own national identity and
became a thriving metropolis today
Singaporeans enjoy the second highest
standard of living in Asia after Japan
and Singapore is an integral part of the
world's trading and economic system how
this was achieved and how Singapore
created national wealth from illness in
auspicious beginnings
is the focus of the next part of my
speech when Singapore became independent
in 1965 the British left the island with
a relatively well-developed legal system
a functioning civil service and a good
port together with a strategic
geographical location these assets led
to the commerce and trading sector
becoming the pillar of growth for
Singapore at a time but dependence of
the Singapore economy on trade had its
limitations a growing rapidly growing
population increased pressure on the
capacity of the Singapore economy to
meet their needs unemployment was common
the physical infrastructure of the
island was inadequate and under
tremendous stress it's night-night
housing was poor slums were abundant and
this was only 34 years ago slight then
poverty plagued the majority of the
islands population the absence of
domestic market or hinterland because of
the separation from Malaysia compounded
the economic problems that Singapore
faced in those early years of our
nationhood but worse there were signs
that the enter code trade on which
Singapore then depended to earn a living
was tech needing new ways of life of
leveraging on the antipode trade to
create new economic growth had to be
found the withdrawal of the British
forces from Singapore in 1968 three
years of Singapore gained independence
was not only a major economic blow to
Singapore but also created a security
vacuum for the island
and consequently the first tasks of the
newly independent government in
Singapore was a bill a defense
capability base or national service
because of our small population which
could secure the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of the new nation
on the economic side the withdrawal of
British forces and the closure of
British bases cost Singapore one-fifth
of its GDP so newly independent
Singapore had to quickly overcome the
major problem of unemployment the way
the Singapore government went about this
was too aggressively build
infrastructure we had a massive public
housing program in order to house
Singaporeans we built roads bridges
ports airports telecommunication
facilities and all of these proceeded at
great haste and at the same time a
unique tripartite partnership between
employers trade unions and the
government was established which allow
Singapore to mobilize these domestic
labor resources quickly and effectively
next slide the government also plays
great emphasis on education and training
because we were else Island was small
population we provided places in school
for every child of school-going age we
created technical colleges to impart the
technical expertise required by the
newly established companies in Singapore
we also established universities this is
the Nanyang Technological University
which was established in 1980 and in
which MIT has been very much involved
these universities were created to
ensure the Bry Singaporeans could attain
the highest academic qualification
fortunately all this happened at a time
when the world was experiencing rapid
expansion in trade world trade grew at
more than 8 percent per annum between
1963 and 1973 compared to 5% per annum
in the preceding 10 years increasing
numbers of investors from industrialized
countries were seeking low-cost
production bases overseas to supply the
world market as well trade boom
Singapore the boom and was able to
revitalize its economy now go on to the
next phase now which lasted from about
1965 from the time Singapore became
independent to the early 1980s when
Singapore became independent many
countries in the developing world look
upon Western multinational corporations
or MNCs as unwelcome remnants of
previous imperiously imperialist
era but Singapore which was desperate to
create jobs for growing population
actively and deliberately courted MNCs
attracting them to locate operations in
a new industrial estates which had
quickly been established an Economic
Development Board was set up which
adopted a multi-faceted approach to
Investment Promotion involving
coordinate coordinated industrial policy
identification of new business
opportunities manpower development and
active industry development the aim of
the Singapore government was to create
liberal and investor friend
investment regime which would allow a
menses freedom in corporate ownership
and in the the repatriation of profits
ultimately our aim was to create within
Singapore first well operating and
living conditions but essentially at
that world cost and our success in
attracting MNCs was a key to Singapore's
rapid growth as a manufacturing center
for export oriented industry
this shows the growth of the GDP growth
consequently Singapore's real GDP growth
rates averaged phenomenal 13 percent per
annum in the 10 in the years from 1966
to 1973 with the success of
industrialization Singapore not only
achieved full employment by the 1980s
but was importing increasing numbers of
foreign workers to ease a growing labor
shortage rising wages and inflation
became concerns for Singapore's economic
competitors we had to again restructure
our economy but this time consciously
moving away from labor-intensive
activities to US capital intensive
industries that favor high wage high
value-added jobs while Korea and Taiwan
were aggressively targeting
technological development to their own
indigenous companies Singapore continue
with the MNC partnership strategy and
encouraging multinational companies to
evolve from a predominantly
manufacturing role to one that encompass
product development
and design responsibilities the growth
of seaport airport telecommunications
financial and tourist services
strengthen Singapore's economy this is a
pie chart of our economy last year with
manufacturing accounting for 23 percent
of our GDP second highest the highest
will be in financial and business
services to it
29% France for the coming 10 percent
commerce 18 percent which is a
significant change because this sector
would have been the majors sector when
Singapore became independent and other
sectors 12 percent so by 1997 the
Singapore economy had become a motive
multifaceted economy which sustain us in
good state where the economic crisis hit
the region last year by the late 1980s
Singapore had joined the ranks of the
newly industrialised economies and I
built up a diversified economy where
trade was supplemented by manufacturing
transport and communications banking and
finance and tourism in over the next two
slides please this is a picture of our
central business district today in
Singapore that's our new a party line
which was built a few years ago the
success of Singapore's
ability to create national wealth and to
improve the standard of living of his
people in the 33 years since our
independence in 65 can be seen by
comparing some social indicators from
the 1960s to the present time these are
some of the social indicators let me
take the first one which is life
expectancy life expectancy increased
from six or seven years in nineteen
sixty five to seventy seventy years by
nineteen ninety seven home ownership in
1965 when became independent only twenty
nine percent of Singaporeans own their
own homes and by 1995 the ratio had
increased to 91 percent this shows the
number of telephone lines so put in a
different way the number of telephone
lines increased from 17 17 percent
sharing one line in 1965 to just two
percents sharing one line in 1997
thirty-five years ago less than half of
all Singapore households with all
television sets today there is at least
one television set in every home
infant mortality a drop from a high 20
per 1000 births in 1965 to a no 3.3 per
1000 births today
and finally university education in 1965
only 3% of every cohort entered
University in Singapore and by 1996 this
has increased to 22% what I've described
so far is what has happened to Singapore
up to now I think what is more important
is what will happen in Singapore from
now on and to answer this question we
have to look at the present situation
not only in Singapore but also in the
Southeast Asian region
been said and written about the causes
of the economic and financial crisis in
Southeast Asia and East Asia we started
with the devaluation of the Thai
currency the Thai Baht in July 1997
within the period of one year enormous
wealth has been wiped out from the
countries in Southeast Asia and the
extent of devastation in the Southeast
Asian economies can be seen from the
movements in the survey's Asian
currencies and stock markets could have
charred one piece which shows dropping
the currencies was head of course has
been the Indonesian Rupiah which has
dropped to about 23 percent of his value
compared to July 97 within the course of
one year the others have been a Thai
Baht the Malaysian Ringgit and the
Korean Won Singapore itself has
depreciated by about 50 percent since
July 1997 but we have been relatively
unaffected compared with our neighbours
this in addition to the currencies the
falls in the regional stock markets were
just as severe and in some case even
more than our chart - since first of
july 997 the stock indices in the
regional stock markets in Southeast Asia
have fallen by between 30 to 60 percent
the show's drop in the stock markets in
our part of the world if you combine the
stock markets together with a fall of
currencies in terms of US dollars
the Falls have been in the order of 80
to 90 percent and I'm told that today
the market capitalization of a single
large American company like IBM or
Microsoft would be more than the
combined stock market capitalization of
Singapore Malaysia Thailand and Korea
which is an indication of how of how
much wealth has been wiped out from the
region in the space of one year the
severity and the protected nature of the
Asian crisis caught everyone by surprise
after all East Asian countries had good
macroeconomic fundamentals we had high
GDP growth no inflation and high savings
while it turned out that good
macroeconomic fundamentals alone were
not enough for example high savings
alone were not enough these high savings
had to be intermediate efficiently by
sound domestic banking systems and in
general East Asia institutions had not
kept up with a rapid pace of growth in
their economies in the last few years
one example is at Southeast Asian
banking systems were not equipped to
handle a large inflows of capital into
their economies in the 1990s could have
chart 3
this shows the net private capital
inflows into Asia and into the
developing countries the top line shows
the total net capital inflows all
developing countries and this is the one
that shows the flow of capital to Asia
in the six years between 990 to 996 the
flow of capital from in from industrial
countries such as the United States to
emerging markets increase five times
from 40 billion dollars u.s. in 990 to
200 billion
u.s. in 1996 and developing Asia absorb
almost half of all net private capital
flows into developing countries in 994
to 996 and when confidence F is Asia so
large outflows of capital within a very
short time the end of the economic
crisis in Southeast Asia and the
restoration of economic growth can only
come about with the establishment of
properly regulated and well supervised
banking and financial systems
this will take considerable time and
effort to achieve but if the
government's in the region have the
necessary will and determination and
assisted by multinational agencies so
yes the IMF and the World Bank I'm
confident that the regional economies
can return to the path of sustainable
growth within a period of three to five
years in a meantime the main worry is
Indonesia which has seen violent turmoil
in recent months it is a great relief
that a smooth peaceful political
transition has taken place in Indonesia
with present habibi taking over from
Swatow and we across hope that political
and social stability can be quickly
restored in Indonesia so that economic
progress will be possible with Indonesia
occupying such a large and important
role in Southeast Asia a prosperous and
stable Indonesia will be beneficial for
the whole region
let me now focus my remarks on Singapore
although Singapore is largely escaped
the economic storms which have affected
service Asia we have not been totally
unaffected
our commerce and financial services
sectors have been most severely affected
by the regional downturn
tourism and tourism related industries
for example have been hit by the plunge
into his arrivals as tourists from the
ASEAN countries and newly industrialised
economies account for about half of our
total visitor arrivals growth in our
exports has also moderated due partly to
weaker regional demand however the
impact of the crisis on Singapore has
been cushioned by the strength of the US
and European economies for example based
on 996 data more than half of
Singapore's
electronic exports go to the US and the
European Union today Singapore is a
largest manufacturer of these drives and
a bulk of Singapore's
foreign direct investments also come
from developed countries such as the
United States Japan and Europe and most
of our manufacturing products are
exported to the OECD markets we will
continue to strengthen our civil and
business institutions in Singapore and
make sure that resources flow into
productive areas
for example Singapore took steps in May
9 96 to prevent a type of asset bubbles
particularly in property prices which
has added to the problems of our
neighbors
this shows the property prices and the
measures taken by the government in 986
in order to slow down the growth we just
shown gentle Downton but other collapse
which has happened in Indonesia Malaysia
and in Thailand so as a result asset
prices in Singapore have not taken a
large fall which would otherwise have
had a devastating effect on the
Singapore economy the exposure of
Singapore's companies and banks to the
region although not negligible have also
not been large enough to be
destabilizing for the Singapore economy
so let me sum up by saying that in spite
of the regional economic crisis
Singapore's macro for economic
fundamentals and institutions remain
South Singapore has large foreign
reserves positive current account and
physical surpluses and no external debt
we also have a sound banking sectors
sector and strong institutions and a
stable government to prepare for the
longer term and to guard against a down
slowdown in business Singapore s of
watches business cause carefully to
ensure that we remain competitive at the
same time we are enhancing our
capabilities and accelerating the
building of good physical infrastructure
when the countries in the region resume
their growth as they will one day
Singapore is well-positioned to continue
its traditional role as the Gateway to
the regional service Asian
countries although this tragedy of
developing Singapore as a as a
multi-faceted manufacturing and services
hub has been successful this does not
mean that Singapore can afford to rest
on his laurels I believe that it was
Andy Grove of Intel which made the
remark that only the paranoid survive
and the truth is that we have to take
cognizance of fundamental changes in the
world's economy particularly for small
country like Singapore and just saw
economic strategy from time to time in
order to continue our growth and
progress so I'll conclude my speech now
by describing how Singapore sees the way
ahead we believe that in the 21st
century the world will be dominated by
knowledge industries with technology and
information processing spurring growth I
think that President Clinton referred to
this in his commencement speech
yesterday and for Singapore to further
progress we must transform our economy
to a knowledge-based economy which
stresses skill and creative people as a
main pillar of growth for the economy
this means that a good education and
training system covering not only the
pre-employment stage in schools and
universities but also the in employment
stage in companies as well as the
ability to acquire process and create
new knowledge will be a country's key
competitive advantage in the years to
come Singapore's economic growth will
come from our ability to leverage of our
own or human capital and to enhance the
skills of our people to develop a
knowledge-based economy in Singapore we
are undertaking three initiatives first
we are revamping our school curriculum
taking steps to enhance thinking skills
and innovation in our schools under the
slogan thinking schools learning new
nation our aim is to promote a learning
culture within Singapore and at the
tertiary level in our universities we
are revamping the curriculum in order to
enhance broadening of our Lapine skills
as recommended by an international
academic advisory panel which met in
Singapore in August last year and Dean
Robert Brown is a very valuable member
of the panel we've also taken advantage
of our links with established
universities overseas to review our
curriculum the MIT School of Engineering
for example is finalizing a year-long
review of engineering curriculum in the
universities in Singapore which will
result in large changes the second
initiative is that we are formulating a
strategy for lifelong learning so that
people who are doing work will continue
to be trained for a person to remain
employable drove his working life in a
21st century he or she will need to
change his or her career several times
and this means that people must be
prepared to learn new skills throughout
their lives the single the Singapore
Ministry of Manpower
and a Ministry of Education implementing
a national strategy to ensure such
lifelong learning and to encourage our
workers to continue to upgrade
themselves continuously third we will
continue to liberalize our economy and
open our markets including the markets
in services like finance and
telecommunications and encourage a more
entrepreneurial spirit in Singapore in
the years to come we see economic growth
in Singapore
coming not only from large companies but
also increasingly from small nimble
companies which can spot emerging trends
and react more quickly than large
organizations to foster enter proneural
activity we were we are making changes
in the structure of our economy like
taxation and regulation and these have
to be implemented expeditiously
but without lessening the prudence and
efficiency which have made Singapore
attractive to investors both
domestically and worldwide finally
crucial to Singapore success in the
coming years will be a welcoming
attitude to foreign talent who can
supplement Singapore's indigenous talent
pool and help to enhance our
competitiveness and further strengthen
our our economy like the United States
Singapore is ultimately a country which
has been built by immigrants who seek
who come in search of a better life and
so long as we open our doors to able
people want to live and work in our
country so long will Singapore continue
to thrive and prosper
ladies and gentlemen during last three
decades Singapore has grown from a poor
underdeveloped country with high
unemployment and a per capita GDP of
less than us $500 to become a nation
city-state of 3 million people with full
employment and a per capita income of us
$18,000 last year from the start we had
come to assim to
and clear realization that Singapore is
a small fragile nation with almost no
natural resources had to plug the cell
firmly to the global economic network to
survive and we all a special debt to the
United States for your leadership in
resisting protectionism championing free
trade and keeping international markets
open
fortunately years of heeding the
discipline of the markets have prepared
us to handle the present uncertainties
in the region calmly and deliberately
the creation of wealth is an ongoing
process which requires constant
attention effort and development the
present economic crisis which is CP
which is sweeping East Asia shows how
easy it is for Prosperity which has been
built on unstable foundations to crumble
to dust vision hard work and proneural
skills and sound leadership have been
responsible for Singapore success and
these are the same qualities which have
made a mighty the leading University in
the world today in science and
technology thank you very much all of
you were happy enjoyable day
[Applause]
good morning
let me echo the sentiments expressed
already about how pleased I am to be
part of this very distinguished panel
and clearly to be honored to be part of
a very exciting Alumni Weekend clearly
the topic at hand here in terms of
building wealth is equally relevant and
important and I just want to express
before I get into the core of my
comments the extra significance to me
personally of MIT and the clear and
strong links that MIT has to another
institution which means an awful lot to
me and that is murk and in thinking
about that I think I could I could
capture that in a very brief way to echo
what Chuck reminded us about which is
the founding mission of MIT and that
rests on the linkage of the practical
application of research to industry and
when I think about that and I think
about Merck I would say it's epitomized
by the hundred and thirty-eight
graduates of MIT who participate at
Merck predominantly in our research
laboratories and in our manufacturing
enterprise and also the great fraud and
great expectations that we carry at the
inception of a five-year fifteen million
dollar research collaboration that we
have instituted between Merck and MIT
but now let's get down to the topic and
talk specifically about building
national wealth through investment and
innovation and I'll start with the
premise that pharmaceuticals compared to
many other industries is actually not a
capital intensive business yet it does
take significant investment in financial
and physical capital to get our job done
actually at Merck if you add up what we
have in our books today in property
plant and equipment it totals about
twelve billion dollars but our
industry's wealth is created primarily
through intellectual capital and here we
are ahead of the
and you'll hear in my comments an
echoing of the presentations that just
proceeded because in today's Information
Age financial and physical capital no
longer are the key assets the only
strategic imperative is knowledge and
for this reason alone the
knowledge-based pharmaceutical industry
serves as an excellent case study in
building wealth our success is a
function of let's try three P's people
patents and patients they are the keys
to how we build wealth through
investment and innovation people are
employees drive our ability to leverage
knowledge effectively patents are the
pharmaceutical industry's mechanism for
protecting and promoting discovery and
our relationship with our patients the
real benefactors of our innovation is
what ultimately builds social and
economic wealth okay given these
insights what are the factors that have
propelled the US pharmaceutical industry
to be a global leader and how can other
US knowledge-based industries use these
same factors to strengthen the national
economy let's begin with investment the
US pharmaceutical industry leads all
other industries in research and
development investment US industry in
general overall invests less than 4% of
sales in R&D in contrast America's
research-based pharmaceutical companies
will spend more than 19% of sales or
twenty billion dollars on R&D in this
year and alone which also record
represents a tripling of the amount
spent only ten years
now what may seem counterintuitive at
first glance is that the industry
sustains this high level of investment
despite the inherently risky nature of
our R&D process to cite one example only
one in about 5000 compounds screened in
our research labs becomes a prescription
medicine from discovery to lab testing
to animal testing to human testing to
regulatory approval takes about 400
million dollars on average and 12 to 15
years and with all of that only three
out of ten marketed prescription
medicines actually recoup the cost of
this investment so many skeptics are
right to ask why bother actually the
odds are better in Vegas and as a matter
of fact returning to my economic roots
there exists a concept in the world of
economics that's called gamblers ruin
and simply stated what it means is that
as long as you get an adequate return
you can stay at the table despite the
fact you're playing with high stakes but
the catch is that you better understand
the risks or you may lose everything and
herein lies the paradox of
pharmaceutical R&D the way to deal with
high risks is to invest more now
ironically with all of this people only
see the big payoff from breakthrough
drug but they aren't there in our labs
as I have been
when compounds fail and they don't
witness the many products that actually
fail commercially it's actually sort of
like assuming that all movies are box
office successes like Jurassic Park and
for those of you who have any memory of
a great failure that none of them are
water world's but in both cases
people miss the investment paradox now
let's move on to innovation maybe the
best way to shape this discussion is
again to pose two questions first on a
micro level what conditions have to
exist for an individual pharmaceutical
company to be successful as an innovator
and then on a macro level what
conditions enable industry overall to
contribute to economic growth through
innovation again with RMIT heritage I
want to cite dr. Rebecca Henderson who
shed light on these macro level issues
by asking the following is it enough to
invest large amounts of money in R&D and
assume innovation simply will follow her
answer was no innovation needs to be
managed those companies that remain
innovative over time
first keep connected to the scientific
community
second allocate scarce resources
effectively and third manage
organizational design appropriately so
let's look a little closer first keeping
connected to the scientific community is
critical because innovative
pharmaceuticals require more than
industry can do alone without an
historic research partnership with
government and academia our US
pharmaceutical industry would not be
nearly as productive as it is today at
Merck we pride ourselves in having
strong in-house research capabilities
but that doesn't preclude us from having
our scientists go outside to publish in
scientific journals attend conferences
and collaborate with scientists and
leading universities as I indicated
earlier and it's through this peer
review that scientific knowledge
advances one term that we use to refer
to this is external
Ardi spillover now turning to allocating
scarce resources effectively this too is
critical because the road to drug
discovery and development is costly it's
long and it's stochastic at Merck we are
currently spending a record 1.9 billion
dollars in R&D 1998 but to dr.
Henderson's point it's not just the
amount of research investment that
maximizes innovation its how effectively
we allocate those Rd resources that
create a critical competitive advantage
so our strategy is specific focused
concentrating on diseases with large
patient populations and then we want
novel products that are potent well
tolerated convenient to use and with
clinical results that are meaningful to
physicians and patients and finally
managing organizational design
appropriately is also critical to
managing innovation here professor
Henderson found that organizations
typically choose to organize by function
or to organize by project organizing by
function ensures that the specialized
knowledge necessary for long-term
innovation is preserved while organizing
by project encourages rich communication
across functions observation the most
successful pharmaceutical companies are
never satisfied with one approach these
companies benefited from internal R&D
spillover that resulted from a
communication across both function and
project lines so ideally the individual
pharmaceutical company must do three
things to succeed keep connected to the
scientific community allocate scarce
resources effectively and manage
organization design appropriately and
let's not forget
these hold true for the success of other
knowledge-based industries as well now
let's turn to the macro level here we
believe there are five enabling
conditions for pharmaceutical innovation
preserving the u.s. free market
continuing support of basic research by
the federal government protecting
intellectual property at home and abroad
streamlining our regulatory system and
creating a global business environment
conducive to innovation the first
enabling condition for innovation is to
maintain a free market in the United
States a free market is clearly
important to all industries because that
is what attracts investment and rewards
innovation and for a high risk industry
like pharmaceuticals a free market is
critical other countries have actually
seen the chilling effects of policies
that restrict access to medicines
control prices or ignore intellectual
property rights it's actually very close
to home take our fenceline neighbor
Canada in the 1970s and 80s Canadian
patent law allowed generic copies of
existing patented drugs to be sold on a
virtually unrestricted basis through
compulsory licensing the result of that
was lights went out in Canadian labs as
Merck and many of our other competitors
significantly reduced investment in
Canada now contrast this with post 1987
and again in 1993 when the Canadian
Parliament enacted legislation to
protect patented medicines Merck and
many of our other colleagues responded
and for Merck we responded through our
subsidiary Merck frost with a 63 million
dollar investment in a Center for
therapeutic research the result for us
our scientists discover
and developed singulair a revolutionary
treatment for asthma for children and
adults but it didn't just benefit human
health and it didn't just benefit the
pharmaceutical industry it boosted
Canada's balance of trade and economy a
second enabling condition for innovation
enables mandates pardon me that the
federal government's continued support
be there for basic biomedical research
again there's a symbiotic relationship
that we have to pursue here both basic
and Applied Research are needed to drive
innovation it's a collaborative effort
and each of us have special and distinct
competencies in that regard historically
as you know government through grants to
America's research universities
exemplified by MIT advances basic
research and then in the case of
pharmaceuticals think about the advances
that's been able to provide in
understanding how the human body works
revealing pathways of disease and
developing other critical technologies
industry then weighs in and applies this
information through our research
investment to the next steps of research
discovering a compound and then carrying
it forward through clinical trials
process development manufacturing and
distribution now I saw a fantastic cover
of The Boston Globe this morning so I
don't want you to totally miss read my
interest in the Boston Globe by the next
comments that I'm going to make but
unfortunately there is a recent
reference in the Boston Globe that
illustrates the fact that the public's
understanding of these complementary yet
unique roles is flawed according to this
article in The Globe industries use of
government-funded basic research is and
I quote a pattern of scientists and
universities cashing in on
government-funded inventions close
to illustrate the counter to that 97% of
prescription medicines available in the
u.s. today came through the high-risk
pipeline of the industry not government
and industry couldn't have done it
though without the collaboration on the
basic research side this lack of
understanding of the government's role
in science and technology as we all know
carries over to Congress where some
would like to shift the funding focus to
Applied Research such as product or
process development these are the areas
where the pharmaceutical industry excels
and if Congress shifts priorities the
advance of basic knowledge could be
slowed and our research system could be
thrown out of balance with a resulting
negative impact on the US economy
not to mention patient welfare Chuck
vest underscored the importance of
public funding of basic research in his
testimony before the House Committee on
science in March he said there is a
generally accepted proposition that
innovation is the principal engine of
the US economy our present and future
economic strength depends on an
innovation system that has been since
the end of World War two the envy of the
world
I believe that government at all levels
plays a crucial role in supporting that
system namely through encouraging and
funding research partnerships between
universities and Industry let's turn to
the third enabling condition the need to
protect intellectual property at home
and abroad
remember patents is one of those three
P's which are the cornerstones of
innovation along with people and
patients we're fortunate to have a
strong strictly enforced patent law in
the United States this gives companies
like Merck an incentive to make the
decade-long investments in R&D
and also gives our shareholders a fair
return in fact the World Bank funded the
study at the University of Pennsylvania
which estimated that without adequate
patent protection over two-thirds of new
pharmaceuticals would never have been
introduced and we've made progress in
recent years especially through the
general agreement on tariffs and trade
but it's estimated that in some
countries including Argentina India
Turkey Egypt patent piracy costs
legitimate pharmaceutical companies 1
billion dollars a year and piracy can
thrive even despite strong national
intellectual property laws on the books
through our trade association Pharma the
US pharmaceutical industry works with
the US Trade Representative and the
World Trade Organization when company
countries fail to enforce or comply with
the letter and the spirit of
intellectual property laws in South
Africa for example the US Trade
Representative placed the country on a
watch list after President Mandela paved
the way for parallel imports and
violated patent rights now the fourth
enabling condition for innovation is a
regulatory environment that is effective
efficient and puts patients first the US
has long led the world in the discovery
of important new drugs but historically
too many of these new medicines were
available abroad before they benefitted
patients at home because of the delays
in the approval process by the Food and
Drug Administration it's critical of
course that the FDA both protects
patients and improves new medicines in a
timely fashion and in order to
accelerate drug approval the
Prescription Drug User Fee Act was
reauthorized last year mandating that
the FDA reduce review time to 12 months
or less and the FDA has
kept its word for example returning to
singulair the asthma medicine I
mentioned earlier it was approved by the
FDA in February of this year 1998
exactly one year after our company
submitted our new drug application to
the agency and the FDA also recognizes
that because we are dealing with the
health of people there are cases that
deserve special attention so the
agencies accelerated drug approval
process new medicines that can mean life
or death for patients receive
expeditious review one such case was
mercs drug Crixivan for AIDS on March 13
1996 the FDA approved Crixivan just 42
days after the drug was filed the
fastest approval in the agency's history
and now the last the fifth enabling
condition for innovation is policies
that help create a global business
environment conducive to innovation many
economists have pointed to the success
that certain Japanese firms have enjoyed
based largely on national industrial
policies but this success does not
extend to the Japanese pharmaceutical
industry a study conducted at Columbia
University showed that US pharmaceutical
companies are among the most innovative
and competitive in the world while their
Japanese counterparts have remained
among the weakest the study showed that
industrial policy works best in our
industry when it creates a home market
of vigorous competition that forces
domestic firms to develop necessary
competitive skills for the
pharmaceutical industry these so-called
tough domestic markets are characterized
by favorable pricing significant public
funding of research and strict
regulatory approval standards in this
kind of an environment regulators must
approve drugs
not because of local protectionism but
because of the drugs global quality and
innovativeness and countries that have
engaged in these policies namely the
United States the United Kingdom Sweden
and Switzerland have nurtured globally
competitive industries like
pharmaceuticals and countries that have
steered away from these policies such as
Italy France and Japan are now at a
competitive disadvantage while the US
economy is booming and again in the
spirit of not resting on our laurels we
must not forget what led to our present
success Michael Porter of the Harvard
Business School spoke about the growing
threat to American innovation at the
National Innovation Summit here again at
MIT his research shows that we as a
nation are beginning to pay less
attention to the fundamental factors for
innovation especially in research and
education after years of success we are
living off past investments and now risk
becoming complacent but here again the
pharmaceutical industry remains an
exception as measured by the continued
registration of new patents which
support our innovation likewise the
other enabling conditions that made the
pharmaceutical industry one of America's
most successful business stories are the
same ones that will bring success to
other knowledge-based industries when in
place they foster an environment in
which all knowledge-based industries can
leverage their intellectual capital
through investment and innovation
leveraging intellectual capital through
investment and innovation are the
primary driver of how wealth is created
in today's global economy now I know I
gave you three P's as the basis for
success but I'd like to close with a
special focus on just one people and
actually share a story with you that
sound apocryphal but it's actually true
recently one of our newer security
guards at our research facility in
Rahway New Jersey was working the
graveyard shift when a car drove up to
the gate as he watched from the guard
box a man jumped from the car and ran to
the lab he was actually dressed in a
bathrobe and slippers were flying around
and the guard stepped back and said so
this is murk what this guard was
actually recognizing is that innovation
first and foremost is about people it's
people who carry the knowledge it's
people who aspire to discovery it's
people who translate the abstracts of
enabling conditions for innovation to
the reality of building wealth and
clearly MIT and those of us who have the
benefit of time on this campus recognize
this principle and strive to apply it in
our daily lives both personally and
professionally I thank you very much and
I look forward to the participation
later on the panel
[Applause]
good morning good morning morning
I stand beat I just realized I'm on
instead of a coffee break good morning
do you know the difference between
teaching undergraduates and teaching
graduate students it has to do with good
morning when you come to an
undergraduate class half of them are
there half of them are not there no one
sitting in the front row the some of
them who were there or asleep or
drinking orange juice or we hope it's
orange juice and you say good morning to
them and they go if you go to a Sloan
School class or to a leader for
manufacturing class people who have seen
total quality management and have been
trained in the importance of
communication and you say good morning
and they say good morning you go to a
graduate level science class and they're
all there and they're all in the first
row and their notebooks are all open and
you say good morning and they write it
down
and you go to an audience like this and
you say good morning amid audience of
industry or alumni you say good morning
and they say that's easy for you to say
in academia you have tenure
well good morning my topic today how do
I start this did I have the first slide
oh is this a slight thing here I'm a
professor of technology Paul could you
help me or there it is okay was this
from my lecture oh yeah and basically
I'd like to give you a message here
about that could be half-full or
half-empty and following the previous
two speeches we are talking about wealth
creation know things okay it forward
yeah okay but at the same time I'd like
to talk about global sustainability and
that is as we see a world population
grow from the present five billion to a
much larger world when in fact the
activities associated with that wealth
generation can create natural resource
depletion and environmental impacts
which could cause great problems for us
all exactly what will happen what are
the business opportunities that will
grow out of this because this is not
just a half-empty glass I'm not here to
tell you to hug a tree or to shower with
a friend well perhaps not but I would
like to talk about the opportunities
that come from these sorts of problems
and in fact the increased
vulnerabilities as well and give you
some statistics which are probably a
little different than what you have seen
before my job at MIT I'm an
environmental professional one of about
5% of our students and professors and
research are about environmental
professionalism but it's the other 95
percent of you who go out and create new
products decide what materials are in
them decide what those products will do
or won't do decide whether you'll take
back make decisions about where the
resources which will come which in fact
are the ones who drive environmental
sustainability problems and it is my job
as well to worry about the literacy of
these these sorts of people and I'm
going to show you a slide now which was
presented here by Joe Moore Bedok of who
is from Lucent Technologies and it has
to do with market potential for
telephones and if you take a look at the
upper right over half of the world's
population lives more than two hours
travel time from the closest telephone
and the reduce reaction to this is
hot-diggity-dog you know the average the
average woman in in in rural Africa
spends six hours a day simply gathering
the food fuel and water that the family
will need that day the guys are hunting
or watching TV tokyo has more telephones
than all of sub-saharan Africa four
people four billion people of the five
billion people presently on earth don't
have a telephone
hot-diggity-dog let psalms and
telephones what is it about that process
by which they go from not having a
telephone to having a telephone what are
the implications of that for natural
resources what are the implications of
that for the environment what are the
implications of that for our educational
processes and this I think is a problem
that we are all wrestling with and will
cause us great problems because my
premise is that business as usual on
wealth creation will be very different
in the 21st century not just from a
technical point of view and everybody's
talk here about the rapid changes of
technology but from a social point of
view as well I mean what does drive
wealth creation its consumer preferences
and and consumer consumers taking their
wealth and investing it in your products
and we're seeing here an awful lot of
people in the world who in fact don't
have wealth and in the process of the
growth and development that will take
place will begin to have wealth will
they go through the same cycle that we
did of knocking down all our natural
resources creating pollution and then
becoming wealthy enough to to remediate
those problems or will they in fact be
able to to jumpstart to do something in
which they move to more efficient
resource use without having to go
through this cycle now consumer
preferences in the United States however
are not going to save the environment I
mean you just have to look out at the
SUVs that are driving around Cambridge
with rhino guards on the front whose job
are basically to go to this to the stop
and shop or to pick up the kids at
school at ten miles per gallon so and
the United States uses 25% of the
world's energy and and this is made
possible by the other part of what
drives wealth creation which is
government restrictions and innovation
and our government too gives us a
wonderfully cheap gasoline to drive
those those cars and those huge SUVs and
calls them trucks not cars because
trucks have a much more stringent a much
less stringent fuel requirement fuel
economy requirement than cars do so
governments also influence this as well
where will the knowledge and the skilled
employees come from to make this change
if we're going to sell telephones
hot-diggity-dog to all these people
throughout the world where will that
come from as loosin tries to sell
telephones in China as Ford and GM now
try are trying to build cars in China or
in or in Thailand certainly they're not
going to import people from New Jersey
or from Detroit to build those cars or
to manage that process they're going to
be indigenous how is it that these
global networks communicate and
communicate on all directions
particularly the more efficient use of
resources where will your customers be
and who will your competitors be there
are vastly different lot I would suspect
and finally what government concerns
around the world were in
your business strategy what new law
where will make it more difficult for
you to work should Ford or should loosen
be pushed pushing for worldwide
environmental standards or worker safety
standards because that would mean that
they don't have to change their product
or change their processes throughout the
world should they voluntarily try to do
these things all major issues if you
take a look this Glenn terminan of our
Sloan school that's pointed out if you
take a look at the success factors of
industry in the 90s they all had to deal
with globalization trade barriers going
down everywhere everybody going all over
the world into markets they had not been
before sourcing more the international
employee we we saw a tremendous emphasis
on least cost production really
tightening at least cost the costs and
trying to bring them down and increase
in total quality management getting
things right the first time we saw you
familiy right-sizing where is the
corporate research lab now in many of
these places and where are the MIT
programs that turned out PhDs for
corporate research laboratories that no
longer existed then no longer exists now
what does all this mean we're seeing
much much more rapid technological
change and sometimes much more risky
technology change you know Andy Warhol
once said you had 15 minutes of fame
well it seems like products have 15
minutes of life and the winners in one
technology generation tend to be losers
in the next it's a it's a much more
risky business which needs a much more
flexible employee a much more flexible
organization these are the lessons of
the 1990s the environment sustainability
is not mentioned in here or or is it or
is it
actually the environment is really aided
by this if you're if you're if you want
to be a least cost producer you don't
want to pay for resources and energy
that are wasted that come out labeled as
waste and have to cost you 20 times more
to get rid of than it cost you to buy
you want to tighten the process and the
idea of loop closing is really beginning
to increase the efficiency of resource
use decrease the amounts of waste
movement from waste management to waste
minimization from waste treatment plants
to in fact tighter industrial processes
these sorts of things are going on there
then and I think we're seeing some
massive changes in all of this rapid
technological change means that you go
back to a clean sheet of paper each time
which means in the paper industry you're
using chlorine now it's very hard to
retrofit to stop using chlorine and
bleaching but in the next iteration you
can begin thinking about a plant that
doesn't have any affluence whatsoever
does total recycling and therefore these
issues go away
why use something like chlorine so all
of this has been very good for us but
now I'd like to come to what I think are
some of the volatility issues that will
begin to affect things in the future
one is the challenge of the mega cities
these are a large set of cities which
I'll show you a slide of it in a minute
largely south of the Equator which will
grow very very rapidly and the reasons
for their growth are not just that
people within them are having more
children but in fact there is a massive
in migration from from traditional
agricultural activities or land use
activities which are no longer tenable
and these are very poor people moving to
the centres of wealth what will that
mean for markets future energy
technologies the price of fossil fuels
in the world and particularly the United
States right now is just so low that
attempts even attempts at conservation
we're not being much pay back much less
looking at alternative energy sources
we're going through a massive
examination of of climate change now
that we don't have the smoking gun as to
just exactly what will happen there
whether whether co2 is or is not causing
global warming or even in fact if it is
what global warming will mean to us and
and and yet at the same time we suspect
that resource use that is going on and
creating some of these change issues in
fact may be untenable for a lot of other
reasons as well human health and natural
resources you can drink coffee today
it's okay to drink coffee today it's not
okay to drink coffee tomorrow it'll be
okay the day after in fact we really
don't know we really don't have the
science to tell us what is going on in
world trade that trade barriers have
gone down all over the world will
environmental barriers grow up between
them to replace them will we take some
copper that comes out of Chile which
comes out of some of the worst
environmental conditions in the world
but that copper is very clean and then
it comes to the United States where the
US competitors are Superfund sites and
are out of business because they have
such liabilities will there be a barrier
against clean copper coming into the
United States produced in Beart in dirty
conditions let me just turn to the first
slide on megacities and i hope that
comes out well and these are a set of
cities in this in the south and if you
take a look at the set of cities one of
the first time I saw this slide there's
at least three cities on there that I
had never heard of which it turns out
have six to ten million people in them
and then you take a look at the
projection of where that population will
be in a few years say in 2025 and we see
Tokyo not increasing very much but in
fact Shanghai Bombay Jakarta New Delhi
growing tremendously and this these are
you know we can say hot-diggity-dog more
people to buy our goods and services but
you can also say these are basically
poor people a lot of them living under
the bridges living in substandard
conditions and in fact perhaps
destabilizing these cities we're talking
not only about the growth of the cities
but the growth of the importance of
these cities as economic powers even
more than theirs
States and having almost the inability
to deal with these tremendous increases
which could lead to more instability
again the number of very large cities
over three million projected to go from
35 in 1970 to 160 in 2025 most of these
in the South in South America Central
and South America and Southeast Asia if
you take a look at the this graph the
top bar shows the GN the GDP represented
by the city of Shanghai it is in the
order of 10 to 12 percent of China's GDP
and then you see its population which is
much less than that Bangkok with about
12% of the population of Thailand has
almost 40% of the GDP these cities are
enormous magnets as where the jobs are
with us where the wealth is and these
these cities are growing rapidly because
of a tremendous in migration to them and
start thinking about a city that grows
that rapidly and how you provide water
and sewer and clean air food for them
electrical power communications and of
course mobility and transportation since
they must be able to get two jobs this
is a graph of car ownership per capita
increasing from 1970 to about 1990 the
top is the United States we're rapidly
approaching 700 cars per thousand people
the bottom is Japan rapidly approaching
20 250 cars per thousand now the
Japanese are as riches as we are yet
government policy has reflected in this
difference between car ownership we have
cheap gasoline we we have worked hard on
a national highway system tolls on that
highway system we're very low car
ownership there are very few taxes on
cars themselves in Tokyo gasoline is
very expensive if you want to buy a car
in Tokyo you have to come with a
certificate that says you have an off
street parking place for it the
average car in the United States at the
end of 10 years has 120,000 miles on it
the average car in Tokyo at the end of
10 years has 30,000 miles on it and an
inspection system that makes sure that
it won't come back on the road in - in
Japan at the end of that 10th year but
in fact we'll go somewhere else in
Southeast Asia
now Thailand is well it's way down at
the bottom Thailand is about 55 cars per
thousand point zero five cars on this
graph what's going to happen China
China's even less than that what is
going to happen when we redraw this
graft in 20 years and where will their
car ownership be where is where is their
investment in infrastructure for cars in
in alternatives to cars in terms of
other types of transportation to what
extent will information technologies
remove some of the needs for
transportation it was predicted when the
phone came that the telephone came that
this would reduce the need for for
moving people around since the telephone
could replace this I don't think that's
really happened you know will there be a
massive use of information technologies
to take cars off the road because we do
not have to travel to knowledge anymore
knowledge can come to us interesting
question I do spend a lot of time in
Bangkok and a lot of time actually in a
car in Bangkok when you come out of the
hotel in the morning in Bangkok you have
a choice of Mercedes limousine or a
Chevy Astro van it's a very big van and
you generally take the van because it's
got in it a portable toilet a desk that
set up extra power plug in so you can
put in your laptop and your cell phone
because in fact you're gonna spend a lot
of time in that van and why not why not
get some work done
the Japanese already have special
vehicles they're preparing hybrid
vehicles for these sort of congested
Southeast Asian cities now these are
these are speeds and kilometers per hour
and you know a simple little test would
be do we multiply or divide by 0.6 to
get 2 miles and I'm sure that we can get
a consensus on this
I'm never sure but this is not very fast
and stop and think about the pollution
that comes from those vehicles sitting
there and from that energy use if we
take a look at transportation
infrastructure US cities European cities
Asian cities and Bangkok look at the
very difference in population densities
in the Asian cities these are cities in
which the population growth took place
before before the automobile and before
these massive transportation needs and
they are very very dense how do you now
impose upon them transportation systems
so that people can move around the road
lengths per capita in meters in Bangkok
is less than one meter of course they
they can always float their cars in the
canals or wait to the flooding season
and and float them that way
these are the sort of problems that are
developing in these massive cities in
Southeast Asia if one thinks about the
the energy sources and conversion
processes we can make that a little
brighter what is what's taking place in
the center is the energy forms and
what's on top are different and on the
bottom are different sources of energy
that might deal with this particular
problem and right now there is really
only one thing that that that is working
here and that is the fossil fuels gas
oil and coal nuclear is in fact
decreasing in its amount the energy
companies the oil companies in the 70s
when they watched the oil embargos and
watched the difficulties in getting
fossil fuels thought that there might
become energy companies and that they
would invest in energy alternatives and
they took a look at all these processes
the biomass solar ocean thermal
photovoltaics
wind that's all gone now cheap fuel has
driven that out at a time you know the
economists tell us for that the
invisible hand will automatically bring
new technologies in this areas off the
shelf or that it's just sitting at a
research laboratory waiting to come off
the show
from being commercialized I'm not so
sure I'm not so sure whether whether a
glove has to be put on the invisible
hand to deal with this and then
professor Thoreau will come and tell me
how I failed the course again but in
fact I think this is a difficult set of
situation if you look at the present
sources of world power and when you look
at coal which in many parts of the of
the u.s. is a four-letter word but in
fact it is not in China and half of the
north-south railway capabilities in
China are bring coal from the north down
to be burned at five or ten percent
efficiency in for instance in Beijing
and four hundred and fifty thousand
different residential and light
commercial boilers and the resulting
pollution from this very ugly coal is
incredible just just a little bit of an
increase in an efficiency in that coal
use could lead to major reductions in
emissions in that area now how will this
look in the future the percentage of
hydro is going to go down simply because
I think most of the major hydro sites
have been developed the percentage of
nuclear in the nearer in the in the near
hand probably will go down as well
there's a real reluctance to see nuclear
power the people from EDF from
electricity to France have been here to
talk to us about what will happen when
if 10 to 15 years from now when their
existing licenses on their nuclear power
plants come up and in fact public
sentiment will not allow them to be
renewed and they will have to switch
from non co2 emitting fossil nuclear
fuels probably to natural gas right now
China is it's thinking about 50 new
nuclear power plants in a privatized
situation in which they will buy plants
from Germany from from Italy from the
United States from France from Russia
bringing each bringing with each their
own approaches to these technologies and
to regulations of these technologies
it's a frightening thought MIT is
getting ready now to work with Tsinghua
University and
Beijing and the Chinese government on
simply thinking about a regulatory
process for looking at the safety and
efficiency of these of these new plants
which will probably be built whether we
participate in not but if these plants
fail nuclear is out for the next hundred
years all throughout the world I just
for the basis of time I do have several
more slides here on on energy use but
let's just come to this one which is the
relative commercial energy use per
capita in 1992 and it's a with the
United States as a hundred percent and
we see India down at around two to three
percent no hmm can someone make it more
light
after that there's a request to dim the
lights everybody listens to me here Oh
bear with me the one on top
United States the one on body bottom
India this is per capita commercial use
ones 50 times the other that they're not
be light will this continue or will it
not continue
hot-diggity-dog we're gonna sell them
all things that will increase their
wealth what will happen here in terms of
energy use the United States already
uses 25 percent of the world's energy
we've become rich on cheap energy will
there be security problems if we try to
deny where can we possibly deny India
the right to move right up there with us
and finally co2 emissions we see some
negative emissions when when when you're
not efficient in the former Soviet Union
or in Eastern Europe those plants go out
of business when you bring them under
new regimes and as a matter of fact
Europe is depending on a lot of that co2
reduction in those countries to trade it
off against their growth the United
States probably you will be increasing
from its 1990 levels even though its
efficiency is is going up incredibly yet
in Kyoto the United States has promised
that it will do a 7% reduction of these
from 1990 totals doesn't look right
meanwhile when we look at the Kyoto
Protocol there's nothing in there about
the third world and nothing in there
about China or India or Mexico and what
they will do nor no mechanism by which
the first world can help the third world
to make a transition and I think that
that one of the biggest issues will be
this issue of the North verses of the
South and energy use and in cleaner
production the North now has all the
production all the wealth is making use
of most of the energy but we're talking
about
a world in which two billion of the five
billion people are in two countries in
India and in China can we afford to let
them develop in the way that we
developed or will we have to work out
mechanisms to help them do it in a
better way who will pay for this
who will regulate growth and activities
what sort of institutions will grow up
to do this the population redistribution
is social change in this transition from
agricultural resource base to industrial
base is actually quite frightening I
think in terms of what it will mean to
world security
we will see in fact tremendous emphasis
on material bands recycling content
product design but that is lower that is
lowering per product energy use or per
capita energy use and deals not with the
question of the fact that the population
is increasing we will have to deal with
public perception and expectations can
you eat an apple with a lar can should
you not whether using a cell phone
drive you crazy or not having it drive
you crazy there's a great deal of
contradiction here and I don't think we
will ever get the science totally right
so that everybody will ever accept it
and and even if we did different parts
of society will value that science
differently and we have we have
regulatory issues in which the science
is pretty well established but different
countries around the world draw
different regulatory implications from
it and I think that will continue the
issues of sustainability which is I see
the intersection between developmental
and environmental concerns involve echo
efficiency trying to use resources more
efficiently loop closing equity we were
going to have to deal with these issues
of where things are built how they are
built who gains the wealth will we see
the South developing at the expense of
the global environment or at the or
probably what is more likely at the
expense of the north of a northern
standard of living Futurity thinking
about the future and reefs
sources anticipating human impacts and
finally security which i think is an
important issue I'm a water engineer and
the great American philosopher Mark
Twain once once noted that whiskey is
for drinking and water is for fighting
we will we have a fight over the last
drop of water in Mexico over the last
tree in Indonesia and and over the
people in great discontent in in the
environs of metropolitan Cairo if we
consider some of the recent events to
try and deal with these issues the 1992
Rio conference which was about
sustainable development how how the
countries of the third world will
develop in the sustainable manner and
the very recently completed Kyoto
Conference in 1997 about co2 mitigation
both were small steps in the right
direction at least countries were
talking to themselves
we're talking to each other and trying
to learn more about these issues and
either of these dealt with population
issues technology I mean this is a great
institution of technology we used to be
the villains and all this and now we're
the heroes that means we can have all
this wonderful growth and have all these
use all these wonderful resources and
technology will protect us from lack of
ability of availability of future
resources and will protect us from the
emissions isn't it nice to know that
you're no longer a villain well I kind
of suspected all along that I wasn't
that bad
I'm not that comfortable with the hero
role and I worry very much about this we
have no mechanism for addressing equity
and security issues they will probably
have to evolve over time and things
probably will have to get worse before
we will come up with ways of dealing
with this it was very interesting to
watch the United States strategies at
the Kyoto conference I mean they started
with one they switched to another they
switched to another and suddenly a magic
set of technology targets came out which
as an engineer bothered me because I
don't think anybody have has any idea
about how these technology targets will
be
and certainly I didn't see technologists
involving involved in how they will be
said
how will the public understand this and
what is it what strategy should an
industry a government a university adopt
these are long-term issues prepare and
invest for the long term a vision for
the future more flexible thinking and
institutions get the science right
better implementation mechanisms better
education of the public and of
professionals and what does this mean
for the grey lady by the Charles you're
wonderful mamata MIT is changing rapidly
in this and a whole set of issues like
it we have to educate a socially
literate and flexible professional and
the way we present these issues to most
of these professionals we certainly have
courses about the environment and
sustainability but we're very very hard
to get within professional courses
examples of these materials to give the
the correct message that these are
important parts of professional concern
not some extraneous issues that you take
if you think you're interested in it
there's a lot more emphasis on distance
education and cooperation at a distance
in bringing these ideas and we are
trying to move towards greater
flexibility mit is taking a step beyond
in outreach to government industries in
the public and education throughout the
world we set up a joint program on
climate change we have our alliance for
global sustainability which works with
partners all over the world on education
on research and more important on
outreach not just thinking about
peer-reviewed publications that a few
professionals in our own disciplines
read but thinking about how our students
are educated thinking about how we reach
out to the world in in trying to bring
about consensus towards better solutions
and finally we're getting our house our
own house together physically and
organizationally in trying to be a more
sustainable University
and in having the ability to build the
cross Institute faculty and educational
programs that will deal with these
problems now the best and the most
important slide in any lecture like this
in conclusion okay a smaller and faster
developing world presents major
challenges that will require very
different technical social and economic
response anticipate this and be prepared
or be very vulnerable and that's a
message not just to you but to us now
you thought that a slide that was
labeled in conclusion would mean it was
the last slide no preparation will mean
more flexible organizations and
professionals in them new alliances MIT
is forming new alliances all the time
faster technology changes as you know in
particular we're trying to deal with the
technology changes that are involved in
distance cooperation and distance
education better strategic planning well
we sort of do that at this university I
think well yes we do yes my boss just
told me that we do and much more
risk-taking and finally in conclusion if
industry and governments these MIT
catches cold our educational and our
research programs and partners are
changing rapidly as well if we are
preparing professionals for a world that
is changing so rapidly we better know
what's going on out there and prepare
our students to do this
and finally our willingness to take a
step beyond normal academic roles is the
key point for the next decade it come on
back in 20 years and let's see what how
this presentation will look thank you
very much
[Applause]
about a year before the handover in Hong
Kong I was sitting in the business
lounge of the Hong Kong Airport and I
was basically eavesdropping on two
Chinese businessmen in the first half of
their conversation they were boasting to
each other about how they'd become rich
moving back and forth across the
boundaries between Hong Kong and
Guangdong and how they become wealthy
man in it and they were basically
describing that part of China is the
economic Garden of Eden and the second
half of their conversation they were
both bitterly complaining about having
to go to Vancouver because the Chinese
the Canadians were basically selling
passports to Hong Kong you invest two
three hundred thousand dollars lived
there for six months you get your
insurance policy you come back to Hong
Kong and they were complaining because
you can't make money in Vancouver
now the question Vancouver is a much
richer area than the Hong Kong area why
is it that people who could make a lot
of money in Hong Kong saw Vancouver as
an economic desert second puzzle is the
last ten years in the United States the
best ten years ever or the worst ten
years ever we all knows the story about
the best even corrected for inflation
we've created more billionaires than
we've ever created in a ten year period
of time ten years ago there were 13
billion airs in America today they're
170 we have great show and tells biotech
the Internet the stock market is zoomed
up faster than it ever has in a 10-year
period of time inflation zero
unemployment slow and for the first time
in 30 years since Harry Truman we have a
government budget surplus how about the
story that it's the worst decade in
American history in the last ten years
the rate of growth of productivity which
is the ultimate wealth getting something
by putting less in has been the slowest
growing in American history 0.8 percent
per year in the decade of the 1960's
which was not the best productivity was
growing four times that fast 3.2 in fact
is in the Great Depression productivity
grew faster than it did in the last ten
years if you look at total factor
productivity which normally we talk
about labor Pro to it if you look at
total factor product
and the decade total factor productivity
has been zero if you look at real wages
corrected for inflation over the last
twenty five years twenty percent of us
have done very well
our real wages are up substantially
sixty percent of us have done very badly
a real wages are down about 20 percent
and another 20 percent have held even
that's the worst performance in American
history and if you look at the median
family income the median family income
in 1997 is precisely where it was in
1973 after you correct for inflation
we've never had a 25 year period of time
when there's been no increase in median
income and in fact is it's worse than
that because women have gone to work and
worked many more hours per year in 1997
than they did in 1973 this is the worst
decade in American history
or I'd like to imagine that your John
Akers head of IBM it's 1990 you've just
had a decade the decade of the 1980s
like no firm in human history has ever
had over that decade you have averaged
profits between 8 & 9 billion dollars
per year to put that in context last
year the two most profitable firms in
America with almost exactly the same
profits where Exxon and GE and they both
made about 8 billion so over at 17 years
ago and for 10 years you made more money
than the most profitable firms in
America make in 1997 you're the most
profitable company in human history the
most admired company human history the
best known brand naming hue mystery and
if anybody says who do you want to work
for more people want to work for you
than anybody else and in 1990 you have
profits between 10 and 11 billion
dollars no company has ever made that
amount of money before then and no
company has ever made that I'm only
since then and now God comes to you like
Moses and he says John come up the
mountain with me I'm going to show you
the Promised Land this year you're
making not quite eleven billion dollars
next year 1991 it's going to be 0 the
year after that minus 9 year after that
minus 9 year after that minus 5 and over
the next 4
you're gonna lose 23 billion dollars and
no firm in human history has ever lost
23 billion dollars the era of the
mainframe is over and now John it's your
job to go down the mountain and persuade
420 thousand employees who've just had
the best year in human history the best
decade human history that they've got to
all rip it up and do something different
you think you could do that
I don't think God could do that there is
simply no way it can be done now I don't
think everybody's going to fall off a
cliff the way IBM fell off a cliff but I
think everybody is going to have an IBM
experience and to drive that point home
I'd like to read a list of names for you
this is a list of names and it's the 12
largest industrial firms that existed in
America on January 1st 1902 the century
there two things interesting about the
list but only one is really relevant
here they're in alphabetical order so
I'll read them the American cotton oil
company the American steel company the
American Sugar Refining Company
Continental tobacco federal steel
General Electric national-led Pacific
Mail people's gas Tennessee coal and
iron us leather US rubber ten of those
twelve companies were natural resource
based companies but what's the second
interesting thing how many of those
companies are alive today one General
Electric that's why people write books
about General Electric and every one of
them died for the same reason including
General Electric General Electric's
Laboratories invented the transistor one
day after the Bell Labs independently
General Electric was the dominant maker
of vacuum tubes there were five makers
of vacuum tubes in America
General Electric gave the transistor to
the vacuum tube division
guess what the vacuum-tube division did
with it spent three years proving it
wouldn't work there were five makers of
vacuum tubes in America and not one of
them ever successfully made a transistor
or a semiconductor chip because of
course the answer is you have to
cannibalize yourself to save yourself
and who the hell can do that I'll make
you a prediction even a little bet if
you like if we come back 30 years from
now Walmart will not be America's
biggest retailer the other day I read in
the paper that Walmart had opened up an
intellect internet electronics store but
it very carefully priced everything so
it was a little bit more expensive in
electronics store than it was in its
real store because it's got too much
invested in people land in buildings
it's can't have a cheap electronic store
because if it did you'd either go to the
real stores look and then buy it
electronically or you wouldn't go to
their real stores and to CEOs of Walmart
would have to be prepared to lose
massive amounts of money as they close
down this huge operation if Walmart were
to be the leader in electronic retailing
can you cannibalize yourself to save
yourself the general answer is you can't
now I think if your interests in the
issue of building wealth you've got to
think about managing some creative
tensions the first creative tension is
between chaos and order too much of
either is bad and let me give you an
example take Russia in the last half of
the 19th century no Society has ever
been more creative think about the
writers who all existed at the same time
dosa Eskie Tolstoy Chekhov turgenyev
Gogol the list goes on and on and on you
can do the same thing in music painting
anything and their society is about to
collapse lots of chaos lots of
creativity but not the order to use it
or think of a different historical
example of the opposite suppose a man
from Mars came to the world in the 1500s
the 40:14 whatever 15th century 1400s
and it was told some part of the world
is about to conquer the rest of the
world
make it into a colony what part of the
world is the conquer or obviously answer
is China in the 14th century China had
all of the technologies necessary to
have the Industrial Revolution that
wasn't in fact going to occur for
another 400 years they had steel in the
blast furnaces gunpowder and cannons
paper movable type printing presses
compasses and rudders they put an armada
with 200,000 troops on the coast of
Africa they're our biggest ships were
five times the size of Columbus's ship
and believe it or not they knew how to
drill for natural gas but the emperor
said order and none of those
technologies were ever effectively used
the question is can you manage the
tension between order and chaos because
both are necessary to create wealth
the second tension you have to manage is
the tension between individual and
community Judy was talking why the hell
are we leaders in biotech yeah the
answer is somebody in 1960 it was either
very smart or very lucky in the National
Institutes of Health in today's dollars
started putting two or three billion
dollars a year into what was then called
biophysics 25 30 years later we have a
big important industry but somebody out
there in society puts sixty seventy
billion dollars worth of money into the
research and development of building
this industry before it became a private
industry but at the same time those
brilliant individuals and private
companies are absolutely necessary to
make this a success and the answer of
course is if you're thinking about Rd
that's going to pay off more than ten
years so now that basically has to be a
social responsibility if you're thinking
about R&D that can pay off in less than
five years in profitable products that
can be a private responsibility and if
you're thinking about between five and
ten we have to think about creative
ideas as to how you get both of them
worked third tension you have to manage
is between investment and consumption
are you investing the right amount in
the future and I think one this is one
of the places where economics is at
fault because we course teach that the
only thing that creates value
utility is consumption and you have to
ask yourself is that really true or is
mankind to Beaver
you know beavers build dams and cut
trees when they clearly have enough food
for the whole winter and they know it
they're just built to build dams and cut
trees that's what they enjoy doing and I
think the answer is human beings are at
least partly a beaver and if in our
society we throw out the beaver impulse
and we become simply a consumption
Society then we won't have a future in
the United States social investment in
education since 1976 is down 50%
investment in the infrastructure since
the late 1960s is also down 50% in the
private savings rate is the lowest in
American history we are perfectly
consistent and both our private and our
public lives and the answer is you can't
live off the past forever if you're not
willing to invest you don't have a
future
and of course that's the fourth creative
intention one things that makes human
beings human beings is we have a history
of present in the future to the best of
our knowledge no other animal has either
a past or a future all they do is have a
present and the problem is if you think
of our economic system capitalism it's
myopic it can't make the long-run
investments it itself needs and research
and development education and
infrastructure and this is going to be
put into a bad mix by 2020 or 2025 the
United States will have a voting
majority of people over the age of 65
how do you get people who were over the
age of 65 to vote to spend money to make
the future better it's going to be the
big question that our society is going
to have the answer the fifth creative
tension is between competition and
cooperation where you need them both
communism fell because it believed in
cooperation the idea was you would build
the new man or the new woman that
wouldn't be motivated by greed and
individuality would do social good for
the community
it didn't work but the opposite doesn't
work either it's important to remember
that Darwin borrowed the phrase survival
of the fittest from a 19th century
British economist by the name of Spencer
because Spencer believed the only way
capitalism could work is if the fit
drove the economically unfit into
extinction and by that he meant death
starvation and of course that's what
everybody at that time believed that's
what was necessary to make capitalism
successful and it's why Marx created
predicted a revolution because it didn't
happen of course because Bismarck a
great six conservative invented public
pensions in public health care and
Winston Churchill when he was Chancellor
of the Exchequer invented unemployment
insurance so that individuals don't
starve to death
when the economy doesn't want them
because they're too old too sick or
they're unemployed now I think the right
way to think about creating wealth is
you've got to remember one of the
reasons we're creating billionaires so
fast today is we're in the midst of what
historians 100 years from now we're
going to call the third Industrial
Revolution first Industrial Revolution
was a steam engine end of the 18th
beginning of the 19th century and it's
important to remember it really was a
revolution you know Poland marched
armies around Europe 2,000 years after
Julius Caesar but Julius Caesar could
actually move an army from point A to
point B slightly faster than Napoleon
because they both used horses and carts
and roads were slightly better in Roman
times and they were in Napoleonic times
2,000 years of history and not a single
improvement in land transportation but
50 years after Napoleon died and steam
trains are already going more than 100
miles an hour 8,000 years of Agriculture
is over in one country Great Britain has
more than half its workforce out of
agriculture and in the industry the
Second Industrial Revolution is the end
of the 19th and the beginning of the
20th century and two things happened
electrification and the Germans invented
the idea and their chemical industry of
systematic industrial research and
development where you push technology
forward based on scientific principles
rather than waiting for the inspired
tinkerers of Great Britain and of course
it end
completely Britain's economic dominance
in the world because for whatever reason
the Britain British could never shift to
the German model a systematic
academically based research and
development pushing ideas in products
forward but electrification changed
everything it didn't just change night
in the day before electrification the
most expensive apartment was on the
ground floor and you put the servants at
the top with electrification you get
elevators and the penthouse was of the
most expensive apartment you put the
servants on the bottom right factories
should go up to New Hampshire you can
see the steam factories kilometers long
big steam engine at one end a rotor
belts everything in a linear line took
him about 30 years to figure out that
the right answer was not to put a big
electric motor where there used to be a
big steam motor but distributive
processing a lot of little electric
motors on machine tools so you could
organize them in very different ways on
the factory floors and get a lot of pro
tippity out of it we tend to act like
the computer is new in terms of price
declines and performance improvements
but it isn't how much in today's dollars
do you think the first light bulb cost
more than a thousand dollars how many
light bulbs you think you would buy if
they cost a thousand dollars a light
bulb not very many and the first light
bulb wasn't even thought of as a
competitor with lamp oil for light the
first light bulb was in fact used on
wooden ships because wooden ships at
night have got to have a little bit of
light and if you got a storm in a
lantern that means a wooden ship that
burns down and so the first light bulbs
were used on wooden ships as a fire
prevention device and if they'd had a
catalog in that day and age light bulbs
would have been listed under fire
prevention equipment and not under light
and of course that second Industrial
Revolution produced the first generation
of American billionaires Rockefeller
Morgan Carnegie Mellon Kodak Rockefeller
in today's dollars had about 27 billion
dollars Bill Gates has more about
somewhere between 40 and 50 but relative
to per capita income of that day and age
Rockefeller was six times as wealthy as
Bill Gates now why do I say that we're
in the third Industrial Revolution and
that's why we're creating billionaires
today
it's a revolution which is not being
sometimes called the information
revolution I like to call it the era of
manmade brain power industries but it
has to do with a set of industries that
are all changing at the same time which
like electrification are going to change
everything in the way everybody does
everything the industries I think that
would be on the list or micro
electronics biotechnology the new
telecommunication industries new
materials computers robotics plus
machine tool and what's happening this
time of course is in the previous
revolution we went from local to
national economies this time we're going
from national to global economies and
one of the things the difference is of
course is when we move from local to
national economies we had national
governments we're moving from nationally
global economies without a global
government creates a problem what's the
fifth biggest banking center in the
world the biggest is New York the second
biggest is Tokyo the third biggest of
London the fourth biggest is Frankfurt
and the fifth biggest is the Grand
Cayman Islands 30,000 people nobody's
ever been there it's a place you bank
when you don't want government looking
over your shoulder Taiwan for example
makes it almost 1,000 percent illegal
for Taiwanese firms to invest in
mainland China and Taiwanese firms are
the biggest investors in mainland China
bigger than Japan bigger in the United
States all done through the Grand Cayman
Islands coming back in through Hong Kong
these industries are going to change
every other industry in the 1950s when I
was a high school student in Montana we
had what we hoped was going to be a big
oil boom but proved to be a minor oil
boom but in the 1950s the oil industry
was like the James Dean movie giant luck
and brawn punch a hole on the ground and
have a 5% probability of hitting oil you
got about thirty percent of the oil out
of the ground and the people who worked
as roustabouts on the oil rigs were
literally illiterate last summer I spent
some time doing some consulting for
Saudi Aramco the biggest oil company in
the world you'll find three
supercomputers side-by-side they're
doing three and four dimensional
acoustical sounding the hit rates 60%
the extraction rates 80% horizontal
drilling Norway was supposed to be out
of oil by now instead it's the second
biggest exporter in the world after
Saudi Arabia because they can drill them
oil it's water
two miles deep this is now a man-made
brain power industry still makes oil but
the process is so different it's a
completely new interest industry and you
can tell stories and we could take a
long time to do them about how many of
our conventional things are going to
change if you look at electronic
retailing it is very clear that we have
all the technology necessary to close
every retail store in the world and 5000
years ago into your local store maybe
over I don't think it is because people
like elbows and the ribs we're a social
animal but the big thing in retailing is
entertainment retailing you pay 20% more
but you get you have it getting fun
because if all you want to do is buy
good stuff cheap it's always going to be
cheaper electronically you don't need
the expensive people the expensive real
estate and all the things that go with
it and if you want to see that part of
the future maybe it's l.l.bean a store
in rural Maine that now sells 350
million dollars worth of clothes in
Japan and it doesn't have a single
employee in Japan there's a 90 percent
probability if you bought an Easter Lily
the Dutch made the money they didn't
grow the Easter Lily they didn't sell
you Easter lily but they control the
logistics system and 90 percent of the
flowers and the world go through the
Dutch flower auction and all of the
money is in the logistics anybody can
grow anybody can sell but to get an
Easter Lily to you on Easter that's
blooming on Easter that's the trick and
that's what the Dutch know how to do and
these things aren't going to just change
economics the French have coined a term
called the ultra power militarily a
super power is somebody with missiles
and nuclear weapons that can blow up the
world an ultra power and they think
they're only one is the United States is
a power that commands the information
system can see everything can shut
everybody else's eyes and ears off and
warfare is completely different because
you shoot at things over the horizon
that you can't see and it is a
difference on public television here in
Boston they've been replaying the
battles of World War two recently I
watched the Battle of Leyte Gulf two
giant Japanese and American Armada is
steaming
each other and to get within 20 miles of
each other before either side knows the
others there today we know where every
big ship in the world is within 8
centimeters at every moment in time off
the GPS remember Peter Arnett and
Baghdad solar cells off the satellites
that device cost $500,000 in 1991 guess
what it costs today recently I got an ad
it's less than five thousand dollars and
if you don't need the solar cells you
can plug it in you can get it for 2,500
the problem with being able to see the
world is everybody becomes more
sensitive to military deaths here you
got the ultra power and eight people get
killed in Somalia they're all
professionals we put our tail between
our legs and we get out and we're not
peculiar because there's a difference
between reading about 30,000 deaths at
Normandy and seeing one soldier die in
real time on your TV set the problem in
the next Persian Gulf War you're going
to have a thousand Peter our nets and
your enemies capital you're going to be
bombing your own correspondents maybe
that's a good thing
culture culture from now on out is
completely different because
historically culture was older people
telling younger people what the
traditions of their society were or are
today it's what sells it jumps right
across the generations recently somebody
didn't study in the United States among
teenagers how many minutes per week do
you spend talking to your mother and
father and how many minutes per week do
you spend watching the TV said it was
twenty two minutes per week on the
mother and father and eight hours on the
TV set now who do you think has the
greatest cultural impact the rest of the
world see this is an invasion of
American culture but it isn't it's a
brand-new culture there's somebody
Nikken Amish profession who's written a
book called the winner-take-all Society
Pavarotti makes more money than all the
singers in human history combined his
voice is not better than Caruso it was
probably but Caruso was limited to
singing in the concert hall 2,000 people
what can you charge him on CDs Pavarotti
can sing to the world and of course it
means there is no market for second-rate
tenors third-rate tenors or fourth-rate
tenors we tend to forget it but Joe
DiMaggio and Babe Ruth were not the
highest-paid Americans but Michael
Jordan is because Babe Ruth was limited
to how many people can you put in Yankee
Stadium Michael Jordan can play
basketball for the world on TV and he
makes a much bigger income relative to
everybody else now I think the thing you
have to understand here is what I like
to call a wealth pyramid if you think
about the pyramid being widest at the
bottom the pyramid at the bottom he is
are you creating the basic knowledge
that allows you to create the
discontinuities that change history the
reason those Chinese can't make any
money in Vancouver is very simple they
are very good at looking at what's
happening at the developing world and
moving it to the underdeveloped world in
Guangdong but you get them in Vancouver
they've got to have a brand new idea
that nobody in the world's ever done and
they weren't geared up to do that in
Vancouver there's nothing obviously
missing you have to think up something
new one of the things I like to do is I
don't know you let's call it am a
generic history or counterfactual
history suppose I'm a historian in the
year 3000
writing a book about a people alive in
the year 2000 that's us what do you
think they're going to say about us what
do we say about people in the year 1000
people let's say we're alive between 900
and 1150 Rhian in the year 3000 is going
to say these are the people invented
biotechnology and for the first time in
human history plants animals and human
beings are partly man-made and it's
going to happen let's take human beings
first thing we're gonna do is cure
genetic diseases right but now I'm no
longer just made by God suppose I've got
a son that's a dwarf that's a tragedy if
there's some technology can make him
into a normal-sized person instead of
being three feet tall we should use it
right so now he's four feet tall but
that's still kind of a semi right
it's a big handicap to be four feet tall
that's making five feet tall now if
you're five feet tall you're normal but
you're not a man's man I want him to be
six feet tall right and once he's six
feet just another foot he can be an NBA
basketball player make me
you can like it or you hate it but it's
going to happen it's going to happen
well sir first start correcting defects
and then we'll make bigger smarter
suppose you could add 30 points to your
right the IQ of your kid wouldn't you
want to do that and if you didn't do it
your neighbors are gonna do it your kids
going to be the dumbest kid in the
neighborhood of course you're gonna do
that
the second thing on the pyramid is human
capital are we in fact educating the
whole population with the skills
necessary to participate in the process
and we sometimes look at India and we
say they're doing what economists call
the enclaves strategy 200 million
Indians are going to be educated moving
to the first world and 800 million
Indians are going to be illiterate and
state in the third world one I don't
think it's going to work but isn't that
what we're doing in the United States
we've got 20 30 % of the population
where the greatest thing that's ever
happened to them is globalization I make
more income than I ever made before and
we've got 60 percent of the population
where it's the worst thing that ever
happened to him their incomes down 20
percent despite the fact that the
economy's up 40 percent and the answer
of course has to do with their human
capital the third thing on this pyramid
is entrepreneurial skills now a lot of
intrapreneurial skills have to do with
new technologies but we shouldn't think
that's the only thing think about
Starbucks one of Forbes as billionaires
is the Starbuck founder it's genius he
persuaded Americans to pay $3 for a cup
of coffee when he used to pay 50 cents
right that's why he's a billionaire what
you have to have is you think about
intrapreneurial skills is not just the
right invite individuals you have to
have the right environment for them if
you compare Europe in the United States
for example the Europeans have some
problems and I'll tell you what the
problem is if you take the 25 biggest
companies in America in 1997 in terms of
market capitalization you'll find that
six of them didn't exist in 1960 or were
very small Microsoft Intel Walmart
didn't exist hewlett-packard had less
than a thousand employees
if you take the 25 biggest companies in
Europe in 1997 they were all big in 1960
they have been completely unable to grow
any new big companies over this 30-year
period of time but it doesn't have to do
with they aren't just as smart as
Americans fact is they're probably
smarter doesn't they're better educated
certainly it it doesn't have to do with
the fact that they're behind in
technology because in some fundamental
sense they're not the question is have
you created the institutions that allow
those entrepreneurial skills to come out
the next part of the merit pyramid is
what I call natural resources -
environment and I hope that 20 or 30
years from now we don't think of them as
something different I mentioned to you
the Revolution and oil one of the
problems you got is hey good news thing
right a few months ago I was down at the
world offshore oil Congress in Houston
Texas 36,000 people and one of the
geologists for one of the big oil
companies came up do you mean he said
Lester we know where all the oil the
world is going to need for the next
hundred years is for this new technology
the greatest oil play in the world at
the moment is under the Caspian Sea and
there may be more oil in and around and
under the Caspian Sea than there is in
and around and under the Persian Gulf
and there's some signs that there's even
a bigger pool of oil off the north coast
of Siberia in Norway traffic congestion
here's a case where you need both social
innovation plus the technology London
recently did a study about how many
roads would they have to build the solve
London's traffic problem the answer is
you have to tear London down but when I
can put a barcode in every car and a
sensor in every street corner I can do
congestion pollution pricing and I can
let people buy cars and at the same time
run a city that's congestion free
pollution free but it requires social
organization because people have to
start paying for something that they now
get free and the question is who's going
to be good at doing it next on going up
to the peak of the pyramid is physical
capital and as Americans we ought to
think about something
all the evidence shows if you've got
major cities between one to four hundred
miles apart the right way to connect
them in terms of people is not roads and
it's not planes it's called high-speed
rail twelve countries have high-speed
rail
sixteen countries are building it and
the United States is not in either
category now there aren't either two
possibilities they're dumb or we're dumb
they're wasting a lot of money or we're
stupidly not spending a lot of money and
not doing the right things and despite
the train wreck in Germany a couple of
days ago the answer is the rails saves
lives saves fuel saves pollution and is
the right way to do it any question is
can you get yourself organized to do it
now if you think about those parts of
the pyramid at the top you get financial
wealth created out of those
disequilibrium think about Bill Gates 50
billion dollars I'll bet she's never
saved a penny of his income in his
entire life he didn't get rich by saving
his money he got rich by playing the
disequilibrium
as you shift from one technology to
another people weren't dumber and dumber
in the 50s 60s and 70s yet we didn't
create the billionaires we didn't create
the billionaires because the environment
wasn't right for creating the
billionaires on and on the financial
wealth obviously one of the things you
have to worry about is how do you widen
participation something Bill Clinton was
talking about yesterday now when you
look at the whole pyramid I think the
thing you have to think about is do we
in the United States and in the rest of
the world have the concept of what I
call the Builder as opposed to the
consumer are we interested in building
can we take joy in building can we get
utility from building once again when I
was a boy in Montana there was a
railroad no longer exists called the
Great Northern mr. Hill built it and the
Train that went across Montana was
called the Empire Builder he thought he
was going to build a physical empire in
the northern part of the United States
it never happened but it was the right
idea can we have the empire building
mentality not in terms of physical
empires but it turns of intellectual
empires hard facts and wild imaginations
and a hell of a lot of vision a sense of
adventure and it will all be economic
explorers thank you very much
[Applause]
now we have the have the real privilege
of spending about the next 40 minutes
really participating in a dialogue with
everyone here my understanding is there
is a mechanism for getting cards out to
those of you in the audience who would
like to ask questions I'm going to ask
that you submit them to in writing and
then because they don't trust me with
the primary function of a person in a
role like this
Ayana Park is going to select questions
for me then to deliver to the group
perhaps while we are waiting for that
maybe one of you would like to ask one
of the other is a question to get us
moving well they're out of creativity
they're gonna be in the dustbin of
history of the first twenty years the
next century yeah let's let's just take
one more waiting
will singapore be able to avoid the
problems caused by real-estate
speculation running rampant that some of
the other countries in that part of the
world is running too is that a good
summary well I think as I said in my
speech just now one of the things we
have been able to do was actually to
prevent a type of property bubbles which
happen in Japan I think at one stage at
the height of the property speculation
in Japan it was estimated that the
market value of the property in Tokyo
alone was more than that in the whole of
North America so obviously that type of
situation is not sustainable in
Singapore there was a there was a
possibility that we could have had a
safe situation because between 1992 when
1996 the price of property says the
double and if nothing had been done then
we could have a safe situation that has
happened in Malaysia Indonesia and in
Thailand but the government took various
steps in order to restrain property
prices by imposing the amount of credit
that is available for people to buy
property and I think that since then
prices have come down by about 25
percent but in a gentle way so that it
did not damage the real economy or our
banking system so if you want to
speculate in Singapore property I would
say that perhaps just wait a year or so
I think
well the real questions are now rolling
in and there's first one I think is
pretty intriguing how will electronic
cash effect wealth creation
Lester you want to take a crack that's
one of those discontinuities and see on
most of these things it's going to be
sociology that determines what we do and
not technology for example when it comes
to the cashless electronic society the
United States is one of the slowest move
in the entire world in that technology
and there's a very simple reason
Americans love to kite checks you write
a check and you don't have the money
there in three days later you know well
you have money there that's illegal
that's a crime and we all do how many
people have never cut into chickens and
with electronic funds transfer you get
an instant debit and I think we're not
going to do electronic funds transfer in
the United States unless the business
world the banks are willing to say we're
going to do it electronically we won't
subtract the money for three days now if
you could make it happen there's a lot
of money to be made because it's very
expensive to process all these checks do
all this paper bookkeeping but you've
got to look at the real sociology as to
how people live and you can't simply say
hey here's a technology it's a cheaper
technology will automatically move to it
because historically you can point to
lots of better technologies that were
never adopted because of various
sociological realities out there in the
system and you know it's exactly the
same thing on retailing everything is
going to be sellable electronically and
I think we're going to be very surprised
about what people want to buy
electronically and what they don't want
to buy electronically like in Boston
it's supposedly already true that about
20% of the cars have some electronic and
involvement and there's a very simple
reason everybody when it goes to the car
dealer feels cheated because that's the
only place we bargain basically he's a
pro I'm an amateur and even when I got a
good deal I feel like I should have
gotten a better deal and I've been
cheated right and I'm perfectly willing
to pay an electronic negotiator $100 to
certify that I've got the lowest price
in the metropolitan area it makes me
feel good and it's worth a hundred bucks
and so on all of these things I think
the thing that you need to think about
is not what's technologically possible
but what is what is the Sociology in
combination with a technology going to
do and that's where the people make
money when you configure both of those
things together as opposed to just the
technology here's a a very topical and
timely question as opposed to some of
the longer-term ones
and Judy maybe you can take a shot at
this Dave wants to know if it's when is
lunch 30
how will the euro affect wealth creation
that's interesting as Lester was
speaking I was almost going to try to
take it in a little different direction
because there's a there's a there's a
theme in there in terms of at least
reducing to a single currency and I
think there again there's the promise of
great economic wealth because if you can
if you can leapfrog in terms of trade
barriers and tax barriers and other
economic barriers to really foster a
stronger European economy you see great
promise
whether that's doable because of the
things that I just ticked off in terms
of again reducing trade barriers
reducing the flow of employment you know
facilitating the flow of employment as
well as changing tax regimes becomes
extremely difficult it's a sort of a
variation on Lester's theme in terms of
national priorities and national rights
so I think there's a healthy degree of
skepticism we have about the promise but
having said that just giving an example
for our industry per se
leaving aside again the advantages I
think on the currency side in terms of
maybe just coming up with more if you
prompt pardon expect on ik plates
because we're gonna have just one large
currency to deal with and from a hedging
perspective tough to tell what the
volatility the correlations are going to
be like but that's a technical problem
from a business standpoint there's one
great appeal and that is transparent
pricing that I cited a little bit
earlier the issue of parallel imports
and that basically means a violation of
patent rights where low cost payers can
actually permit product to be shipped
across national lines to be sold by
other parties where the beneficiary is
not the innovator but the beneficiary is
the wholesaler or the pharmacist and
what what a single single currency will
do is basically force two single pricing
and transparency and pricing so from
that standpoint it may actually be very
beneficial effect on innovation
again the right kind of price
competition and the right kind of
economic environment let's see let me
make a comment here that has to do with
R&D I think one of the big payoffs in
Europe is going to be on the R&D front
you know if you drill through oil wells
a year you're in a risky business if
your royal dutch/shell and you drill
seven thousand a year it's just
probabilities and the same thing is true
in our idea suppose I'm in Spain and I'm
a government I've got an R&D budget
where do I put my money if I put a
little bit in everything it's all wasted
because it's just such a small amount of
money it doesn't pay off but if I'm
playing this game at the European level
I can afford to bet on all of the
technologies if I do it right and I
think you know for example in Spain
where I've looked at it I'll be willing
to argue to the Spanish waste every
dollar they put into R&D because they've
spread it in such a way they don't get
any benefits and if they if they spent
zero they'd be better off but the right
thing is not to spend zero the right
thing is if you can really coordinate
this in a bigger pan-european thing then
you can get some real payoff of European
R&D that's now hard to get if you're in
one of the small countries in Europe and
maybe even Germany see I don't even
think the United States is quite big
enough to play every technology these
days but we're close and Europe of
course will be a slightly bigger economy
and so I think there may be some real
payoffs in terms of European R&D if they
can pull this off here's one that I'm
going to answer what's the best way to
start when you're young no capital but
good ideas now listen very carefully
because this is the definitive answer be
the first person in line for this
afternoon's session on entrepreneurism
seriously we're gonna have a great
session this afternoon with a lot of
people who have been there and done it
and that's the whole intent of it this
one for 2010 from the perspective of
Singapore as the present government
considered the problem of an ageing
population in the 21st century how do
you think about that issue we have and I
think that one of the surprising things
about Singapore and it is statistically
the most rapidly ageing country in the
world in a sense that the demographics
of our society such that we will move
from a relatively young country because
his Singapore as I said was built by
immigrants to become a society with
large number of aged people more than
two-thirds within perhaps 20-30 years
and it is going to mean enormous changes
in a way we regulate our economy and run
our society the way in which we have
tried to deal with this problem of
hoping with an aging society is to look
at it as a tripartite problem which has
to be resolved not individually but
through the combined efforts of the
individual the family and society for
the individual certain amount of savings
during his or her working life in order
to prepare to have the necessary means
to sustain oneself when you get to sixty
sixty-five and very important to pay for
your health needs and also this truly
second track and that is to emphasize
again the importance of the family we
regard the family in Singapore really as
a building block of our society
and the family unit is still strong in
Singapore family members feel a
responsibility to look after one another
and we feel that this is of great value
because for an aging population I think
in addition to the physical needs one of
the great consequences and the drawback
which many people suffer from is a lack
of social acceptance by the family they
feel neglected they feel that they are
not important and it is here that the
family unit is very strong I think the
difference between a family unit and
other types of social organizations is
that you can choose your neighbors you
can choose your friends but you can't
choose your family I mean you're born
with a family and we will regard that as
something which is worthwhile keeping
healthy finally of course the government
and society as a whole we are trying to
put into place and national schemes so
that to provide essential safety nets
but that but that alone will not be
sufficient and we do not know whether we
have the right answers we have look at
what is being done in the United States
and in Europe it is a problem which we
know will come on to us in 20 to 30
years time and we believe that by
looking at this problem early and trying
to devise a type of organizations and
strategies there will help us to cope
with this problem we hope to be able to
do it much more effectively than if we
were just to neglect it see here's a
perfect example of worry where you get
both a threat and an opportunity because
we were talking about the elderly we
mostly talk about it from their
respective that Tony just talked about
the problems of government and how do
you pay for health care and those things
but it's also a tremendous opportunity
if you take those hundred and seventy
billion airs in America five of them own
Cruise Lines now what do you think
suddenly means Cruise Lines successful
this is a very old technology Cleopatra
had a cruise boat 2,000 years ago he
answers the elderly time money you don't
move we move you on we will you on will
you
don't feel good stay in your state from
the perfect vacation for the elderly and
if you if you lived in Boston last
summer you would have seen the reality
of that because there was a cruise boat
that stuck
it was cruising the Canadian Maritimes
headed to New York and it stopped on an
emergency basis in Boston because flu
epidemic had broken out now if a flu
breaks out you've got a bunch of 18 year
olds no big deal right but on this boat
more than 70% of the people were over 70
years of age and if they're all going to
die they wanted her to die in the Mass
General Hospital and not on the boat
it's made a big market for autos for
elevators and two-story homes where
older people want to convert their house
into a one-story house they don't want
to move to a new house and so you've now
got a market for a type of elevator
where there just wasn't the market for
30 years from go and so you know at the
same time you've got a social problem
some people who become rich basically on
this shift in demography this is just a
warning just a warning to the panel that
there are several questions in here
about your your views on the Microsoft
antitrust matter so I'm gonna ask it
before the days over right now Dave
marks how is the problem of providing
food for the world going to fit into our
economy and our responsibility oh I I
think this is and if you watch for
instance Monsanto and DuPont Chuck sits
on the DuPont board you're looking at
two big what we're formerly chemical
companies now largely moving towards
agricultural and food companies the food
is going to be one of the biggest issues
but in fact I don't think it will be in
terms of traditional agriculture what
we're looking at as Lester has suggested
men altered foods new foods that can be
developed and with less land resources
less water less energy and the difficult
problem will come in in the competition
between food and other types of
resources are we going to use land for
food that might be used for for solar or
for transportation purposes other sorts
of things but in fact the big fortunes
in the future will probably be made in
the food industry and you're already
seeing world industry betting on this
the critical issue in the food industry
is water availability and water has
never gone through the tightening the
squeezing that oil went through when we
saw the oil shocks in the 70s you still
have people growing rice in California
you have no business right growing rice
from California and using six acre feet
of water per acre to produce that and
you're going to find much more efficient
resource use in agriculture to keep up
with the food supply however there is
one estimate that I'd seen that came out
of the world watch in this institute
that predicted that if the Chinese moved
to a habit of one six pack per week of
drinking beer that in fact it would use
up all their water resources I'm sure
that we can find some alternatives to
this
this next question was actually
addressed to luster but I think
everybody on this panel is in a position
to have a view on it and I think in at
least a near term in the United States
it's it's a really important question
could you comment on the fact that much
more innovation is taking place in small
startup companies than large companies
that have tremendous resources and will
this trend continue or do you foresee
reversals Judy you want to start it off
actually well I'll start it off close to
home because I was I thought your mind
yeah I'm looking actually for the
opportunity to maybe editorialize on
what lister touched on earlier about the
genesis of the biotech industry and and
cannibalization or willingness to
cannibalize one's own actually our
industry is an example of a couple of
things including the fact that we're
willing to cannibalize basically because
we don't have any choice we lose a
patent protection let's say in the 10 to
12 year period and with generics which
by the way we totally support the advent
of generics but we lose basically all of
our products so if you want to be a
going concern you have to think long
term to replenish that product life
lifecycle and therefore the whole part
of our our D is regeneration so in order
to be active in regeneration what the
pharmaceutical industry has been able to
do I think too differently than the
vacuum tube and the transistor is to
adapt to change and to basically
metamorphose as technology has changed
and biotechnology is a prime case in
point and actually again I may be in the
wrong economic pew here but what we've
seen is the model as the models evolved
is that biotechnology has been an
excellent laboratory and an excellent
environment for a certain approach in a
certain and entrepreneurial approach to
capitalize on individual ideas but what
it doesn't have is global scale to
really develop those ideas and maximize
the return on those ideas and what has
evolved over that least the last several
decades is a unique kind of symbiotic
relationship between biotechnology and
big pharmaceutical companies because we
have the scale
and there are very few few examples of
biotech companies that have really grown
into quasi full-fledged you know big
pharma companies but I think in the end
that's not necessarily a bad thing
because we continue to have demand and
we continue to stimulate through capital
investment as well as research
collaboration investment and transfer of
scientific knowledge to actually
increase productivity and foster the
biotech industry at the same time that
the larger scale industry serves its
purpose and it incorporates innovation
so it's an interesting kind of a model
that fosters the small Foster's the
entrepreneurial and actually has taught
us a lot of things too that we want to
bring into our own labs because again
for us the entrepreneurial spirit is key
if we're going to continue to have high
R&D productivity which is our lifeblood
so you know it's it's a very interesting
case in point and I think I think this
point about growth coming from small
companies rather to a large large
companies in in our view it's a very
fundamental one because it goes back
again to how national wealth is created
in a country and we feel that that is a
it is the key question which many
countries have to decide on if you look
at the recent economic crisis in our
part of the world and which country is
actually weather the best the answer is
Taiwan its currency has gone down but
the same as Singapore a stock market is
still resilient and I think the key
difference between Taiwan and the other
countries in my part of the world is
that there is very large number of very
small entrepreneurial companies in in
Taiwan which has managed I think to
build on this knowledge based economy
which all of us are talking about and
with the type of knowledge industries
which we feel will be dominant in the
21st century I think there are lots of
opportunities really for young people to
stew to build small startups because you
don't require a large amount of capital
or resources which they need to go into
oil
into larger industries the problem for a
country like Singapore is that we have
been very effective at mobilizing
capital and people in certain directions
and to move into this new strategy now
where we have to encourage small
industries to encourage a more
entrepreneurial spirit requires a major
shift not only in our economy but also
possibly in our social systems because
you don't get entrepreneurship or
innovation without some degree of
messiness in in society and we have been
used to order in Singapore which is not
bad but the question is how can we marry
the two I think this is one of the
tensions which master is talking about
and it's really as a matter of trying of
various ways which we are doing in
Singapore and hopefully come ten years
time we have had to reinvent the
Singapore economy several times from a
trading hub to a technology hub to a
financial hub now we got to transform it
in into a knowledge it's not easy and
there are no guarantees of success in in
anything which we do but I think that
we've one sees that the direction is
clear and the government is prepared to
make the necessary transformation the
chances of success are probably more it
seems to me that there's a strategy in
between here and I that the globe
reported on one recently which is it's
not just our the big industry is going
to do it or are the small industry's
startups going to do it and then become
big industries but it seems to me that
there's a trend now in which the big
industries are watching the small
startups and you start off in the
basement with with two friends and some
savings and 18 months later before you
have a product before you have sold
anything to anybody before you have
accepted even any venture capital you
become an instant millionaire as you're
being bought out by the big companies
and have a set of golden handcuffs to
keep you with that company for a while
this is this is a sort of trend that
we're seeing now the not taking it all
the way but in fact and and the big
companies not keeping their big research
portfolios and big research laboratories
but improving their antennas so that
they can watch the new emerging
technologies come out and pluck them
before they're too expensive and too
right
this next question I'd like to encourage
some sort of quick succinctly answers
it's it's again rather topical it's
question that gets asked with great
regularity in every boardroom in America
is the increasing use of stock options
elusive in lieu of salary a good or bad
thing for company's workers investors in
the nation
yes and no oh by the way it says and why
good MIT I thought you wanted to sink to
answer no I we've actually been on the
one of the companies on the forefront of
going deep and broad in terms of the use
of stock options judiciously and I say
that for the following reasons I think
the advantage is that you I do believe
strongly you align the employees
interest with the shareholders interest
and that's a that's a good thing for
everything that you want productivity
anything else the the counterbalance is
one has to be very cognizant the fact
that these are these are expensive
compensation tools and accounting
standards notwithstanding there's a real
cost to using options and I think
companies like Merck have a pretty acute
sense of understanding how to value
those so that we can look at a total
compensation package and make sure that
we're appropriately compensating people
and know what the value of options are
but in that scheme I think options have
a very very positive effect in terms of
aligning employees particularly
long-term with the objectives of the
company I'm particularly interested in
this topic because I'm thinking of
moving to stock options at MIT and
[Laughter]
here's again one that that is pretty
tough because we could spend hours and
hours and hours on it but it's addressed
to luster given your vision
what should primary and secondary
education be like and how should mi
t--'s undergraduate education change
twenty words or less I think this is one
of those cases you know if you look at
the American secondary school system
it's you know or the total school system
the thing to remember is we're
simultaneously the world's best in the
world's worst all at the same time at
age eighteen were all behind even if she
got the highest cute IQ in America none
of us could pass the French
baccalaureate none of us could pass the
German arbiter
none of us could pass a Korean or the
Japanese exam but then we go to college
and we work a little harder than the
rest of the world and we kind of catch
up because that's you know you go to the
University of Tokyo it's sandbox for
four years and so by the time you're
aged 22 we've caught up and then 15 to
20 percent of us go to graduate school
and most of the rest the world they
don't even have graduate schools what
they call a doctorate in Germany is kind
of the equivalent of a master's degree
in America so 15 20 % of us at the end
end up being the best educated in the
world on the other hand if you take we
got 25 percent of young Americans who
don't finish high school
that's third world right it isn't a very
tough high school and they don't even
get out of that very easy high school
and I think you know the one so one of
the issues is how do you really make
sure that you're delivering some
education to the bottom now we know how
to do that we can do it by simply
looking at the countries who do it well
you got to put some resources there some
focus there and some reorganization
it'll never happen as long as you have
local school boards how do you flunk
your neighbor's kid and get elected to
the school board
you don't write school boards won't set
standards it's just that simple but on
the other hand school boards or Thomas
Jefferson right it's very hard to reject
local school boards so you need some you
need some changes in organization now I
think one of the things you were talking
about is a more intrapreneurial
environment and those can be created
over time and it's see MIT is proud of
its history and it should be proud of
its history but I think the fact of the
matter is MIT today is more
it was 15 years ago and a whole variety
of things have changed that I'll just
give you a couple of examples I'd love
to take credit for it but it wasn't dude
due to myself at all when Jerry Wilson
was dean of engineering and I was Dean
of Management some students came to us
from engineering and manager and say how
would how would each of you guys like to
put up five thousand dollars and we'll
have a ten thousand dollar competition
for the best business plan I'd love to
tell you we thought that was a good idea
but I think the answer is we gave him
the ten thousand dollars because it was
easier to give him the ten thousand
dollars and explain why we were not
going to well then later on I meet a
businessman who's willing to up it to a
fifty thousand dollar competition which
was held here in April now it's a big
event you've got a lot a lot of students
who are thinking about this you know
some of them go into business
immediately some of them go into
business later but see I think one of
the things you have to understand here
is a lot of kind of sociology here again
at a national level plays the difference
you know if you start up a new high-tech
company eight out of ten times you're
gonna go broke or go out of business not
necessarily broke but a lot of business
now your company's failed and you got to
get a job so you got to put on your Vita
Lester Thurow started a company went
broke now does that make it easier or
harder for me to get a job the great
thing about Silicon Valley or 128 he's
probably going to make it easier if
people are gonna say this person's got
energy he's aggressive he's got good
ideas I know that eight out of ten feel
for no particularly bad reason on a
personal level I'd love to hire that guy
we've had some of our Japanese students
who get the entrepreneurial bug and go
back to Japan they set up a company and
fail and what happens they're branded
for the rest of their life across their
forehead failure they never again get a
good job you can't afford to be
entrepreneurial in that kind of an
environment in Japan because the risks
are too high and the question is you
know do you have that kind of in you you
can get people taking too many risks but
here again it's one of the one of those
tensions that you have to think about
socially it should be risky to set up a
new business but it shouldn't be the
kind of thing that's the equivalent of
economic suicide if you try and so I
think you know these things over you
know reasonably short periods of time
can change because I will confess I next
fall I will be I've been here thirty
years and this is a more entrepreneurial
place today than when I came thirty
years ago I'm going to read
questions that were independently
submitted you'll see why and then turn
the whole panel loose on one question I
asked what should what should we or our
government do to improve our
transportation infrastructure that is
speed is the measurement of I'm sorry
the speed of the movement of people and
goods within in between cities and a
second member asked dr. tan specifically
the initial spark for Singapore's rise
after independence was a massive growth
of infrastructure can you comment on how
the investment capital for this
undertaking was raised and successfully
managed so maybe we could start with dr.
tan then asked the somewhat broader
infrastructure question including
transportation for us well I think the
short answer to that is through national
savings what we did it's a couple was to
essentially start a fund called the
Central Provident Fund to which every
employee contributed a certain amount of
this area every month in compulsory fund
and this is matched by a similar
contribution from the employer and this
was put into a retirement fund where the
employee when he retires as 65 could
draw on it to defray expenses during his
or her old age but in the meantime of
course these funds were available and
the government was able to lend these
funds to various statutory boards and we
used them to build housing boats and the
other main component was that we were
fortunate to have a period of very rapid
economic growth because world trade was
conducive to growth at a time it was
expanding at more than 10% a year
because the economy was doing well this
created a great deal of wealth not only
in the corporate sector but also in
individuals and this provided the
necessary amount of finance for
Singapore to be able to build roads
apartments airports and seaports without
having to borrow externally which of
course is a very fortunate thing you
view of the collapse of regional
currencies in the last 12 months I hope
that answers a question other questions
comments generally well I think that
what the American government should do
is if it really wants to be successful
is to do the exact opposite of what it's
presently do doing right now if Lester's
a historian of the 3,000 comes back and
looks at this last part of the 20th
century and asked what was the greatest
impact on American society it will
probably be the interstate highway
system the National Defense highway
system which was Eisenhower rode on the
Autobahn in 52 thought it would be great
if we could move military vehicles
around the country the car manufacturers
and the oil manufacturers thought this
would be a good idea and now we have the
wonderful interstate system which has
led to the demise of the railroads to
people with cheap gasoline being allowed
to live anywhere to do intersection who
off ramps on the on the interstate
system no matter whether you're in
Kansas or in California or New York that
look exactly identical and a district
and a dispersion of people around the
country dependent upon the automobile
cheaper automobiles cheap gas who now
can now not be reached by by public
transportation I don't think we and also
led to the demise of the inner city and
you know to the paving over of most of
the downtown's now this was government
policy government policy cheap gas
government policy cheap roads that would
come out of the tax funds it doesn't
have to be this way and the simply a
more relevant policy about what the
price of energy should be for
transportation would sing early change
what is going on here along with
reinvestments in the type of logistical
infrastructure that we had before world
war ii or even after world war ii in
terms of public transportation and the
ability to move Freight not in trucks
but in other types of vehicles a third
area may well be the way that
information
knowledge ease will in fact begin to cut
into this market for the need to move
goods and services a great distance but
allow them to be produced more locally
assembled more locally and using
information technologies here's
questions submitted by luster throws
publisher last year what do you think
the fourth revolution will be well yeah
the thing that I stand here is if you
take these breakthrough technologies the
people who invent them usually don't
have a clue how they're going to be used
the steam engine was invented because
they had reached the limits of
conventional mining in Europe and they
had to have a way to get water out of
the bottom of the mines and that that
need was what led to the invention of
the steam engine now of course we used
the steam engine to pump water out of
mines but that's not what it did it
created the transportation revolution
where you went from the horse to the
train and all of a sudden you could go
much faster you know I think you know
you're gonna you see the same thing at
the Internet and the thing to remember
about the railroads and this comes back
to this business you both they have the
private and the public sector involved
every railroad east of the Mississippi
River was built with private money every
railroad west of the Mississippi River
was built with public money why the
answer is if you're connecting
pre-existing economic nodes like Chicago
and New York private industry can very
profitably do that and they should do
that if you're opening up brand new
territory the west of the United States
Los Angeles didn't exist San Francisco
existed but was very small then the time
lag before you can make the money is so
big that you have to have a heavy
government involvement and so you see
that in the internet for the first 20
years it's the Defense Department for
the next 10 years it's the National
Science Foundation now it's eminently
supportable as a private transportation
medium and I think it's going to change
lots of things and so here again the
question is do you have the right mix as
opposed to being all all one or the one
of the other and you know here you know
maybe well how much are we going to
travel in the future
well globalization will make us travel
more electronic travel will make us
travel less we don't know which way
that's going to come out but it's
already true and
my life about 10% of the things I used
to go to physically I now go to
electronically and you know here again
it's going to be more of the sociology
and I think the thing that where it
makes a difference is people my age say
something it isn't true what we say is
well that's a nice trick but you'll
never sign a business deal that way our
kids will sign a business deal that way
because to them it will feel perfectly
comfortable they've used it all their
entire life that's perfectly natural you
don't have to have your wife in the same
room with you you can hook up on the
video and it's all the same right
there's only one thing you can't do
electronically well I promised I would
ask it because I think it's been posed
by three or four different different
people here so here it is will breaking
up Microsoft and Intel help ingenuity
and innovation Judy you want to start
[Laughter]
the problem is that it makes sense to
use one standard right even if it isn't
the best because if for example you take
Microsoft it's got a lot of competition
personal computers are only about 8% of
the computer market it's a lot of
operating systems for non personal
computers even on the personal computer
they're a half-a-dozen operating systems
some of them clearly better like apples
but the fact of the matter is it the
fact that the fact of the matter is it
makes sense for us all to use the same
standard even if it isn't the best it's
like the typewriter keyboard which is a
rather inefficient keyboard but it makes
sense for us all to learn the same
typewriter keyboard and I think the
problem is if you broke up Microsoft and
succeeded in creating confusion we would
just might not be Microsoft would be
some other come and we'll all focus in
on one because it makes sense for us all
to have a technology that we can use
even if it is the best and I think the
other thing is happening is this is an
area where technology is moving so fast
it's not obvious that an antitrust case
which takes at least 20 year
settle can solve this kind of fast
fast-moving technology so I you know I
I'm not a big believer that the Justice
Department it's gonna solve a problem or
that there is a problem here because
place a little bit explosion came back
30 years from now will my Christophe and
there is no antitrust case well
Microsoft have its current monopoly I
think it's very unlikely
Bill Gates almost blew it on on the
internet he was at MIT about a year
before he switched saying the most
negative things about the Internet you
can imagine and if he'd been two years
later before he made his discovery that
it in fact is a good thing Microsoft
would not have the position it has today
and it's it's hard to make that kind of
a transition when you're 41 it's
impossible when you're 61 and I just
don't believe I think technology is
moving in such a way that it's virtually
impossible for somebody like Microsoft
to keep a lock on it remember they don't
have the best stuff it's just that we
all have an incentive to use the same
system even if it isn't the best system
because that's the most efficient thing
to do and we're gonna do that no matter
what the Justice Department does and so
if you break up Microsoft there'll be
somebody else will become the new
Microsoft and we'll all use their
personal computer operating system
because it makes sense thank you now I
suggest in closing that since we believe
very deeply an equal opportunity around
here that you folks can go this
afternoon ask Bob Metcalfe the same
question if you didn't like Buster's
answer you can take Bob's it is really a
little past time and we're going to now
adjourn and go across the across the
campus to have lunch together however in
doing that I'd like to throw two
questions out for you to think about and
suggest that rather than panel questions
these might be questions that could
stimulate some conversation around your
lunch tables today there two of them one
how can we as MIT alumni and alumnae
ensure that all Americans at every
socio-economic level are included in the
developing third Industrial Revolution
and the second question which in some
sense is related to this
there's only one woman on this panel
what do you think will happen to the
traditional roles of men and women in
the years ahead so if that doesn't give
you enough conversation to carry you
through until the formal program I quit
but thank you very much and thanks to
our panel
you